Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 47. Ausgabe in unserer Gesprächsreihe rund um Forschung. Und um solche geht es heute auch mal wieder ganz dediziert. Und ja bei schon recht tropischen Temperaturen sitze ich hier und möchte mich über die Wüste unterhalten. Und das tu ich am besten mit Stefan Kröpelin, schönen guten Tag.
Hallo.
Herr Kröpelin, die Wüste das ist ihr Thema, kann man so sagen? Ohne Umschweife, Sie sind Wüstenforscher und wir befinden uns hier auch gerade in Köln, an der Universität Köln, konkreter am Institut für Ur- und Frühgeschichte und noch ein bisschen konkreter in der Forschungsstelle Afrika. Was sehr zurückhaltend formuliert, wenn man hier reinkommt, sieht sehr lauschig aus, die Hängematte hängt im Hof. Ein bisschen was von Afrika hat es auch. Auch wenn es hier so eine verlorene Ecke in Köln ist.
Auf jeden Fall. Und es passt sogar auch zur Thematik, zumindest teilweise, da das ja die ehemaligen Unterkünfte der Ehrenfelder Müllabfuhr waren, die dann eben lange leer stand, nachdem eben die hiesigen Müllabfuhrmitarbeiter ausgezogen sind und dann wurde das damals bewacht, damit das eben nicht besetzt wird so vor gut 30 Jahren. Und das war dann eben der Anlass, dass das dann eben mein Kollege und Freund Rudolf Cooper davon erfahren hat. Der ist Archäologe und der sagt, gut das können wir günstiger bewachen, als über einen Wachdienst. Und so wurde es dann in Eigenregie wurden die alten Baracken umgebaut. Waren in sehr gutem Zustand und es ist halt wirklich eine ökologische Nische hier in Köln Ehrenfeld abseits des Hauptcampus. Und es passt eben auch zur Thematik, denn Müllabfuhr hat ja auch ein bisschen zu tun mit Archäologie.
Und die Räumlichkeiten, die wir haben, großes Gelände mit vielen Stellflächen und wo die Fahrzeuge vorbereitet werden können für die Einsätze in Afrika. Und es sind große Fundbearbeitungsräume, wo wirklich auf hunderten Quadratmetern eben Platz ist für Keramik, für geologische Proben und natürlich auch für die Veröffentlichungen aus dem Hause und für eine Werkstatt. Und ich habe hinter noch Container, die voll sind mit Ausrüstungsmaterial und Proben. Also das wäre schwer, in einem modernen Unigebäude unterzubringen.
Also hier sind alle ganz glücklich sozusagen?
Ja absolut. Also es fällt langsam auseinander und könnte eine gute Renovierung sehr vertragen, aber da eben kein sehr langjähriger Mietvertrag von der Stadt Köln existiert, sollten wir schon mehrfach umziehen, aber zum Glück eben bis jetzt nicht und da nehme ich dann auch eine Einfachverglasung sehr in Kauf, statt dass wir dann in der Innenstadt, wo wir ja Parktisch ja überhaupt nicht so arbeiten könnten wie hier und das ist wirklich eine ökologische Nische. Mit einem kleinen Teich, wo man draußen sitzen kann, wo dann auch gelegentlich Feten von den Studenten stattfinden. Oder jetzt eben vor zwei Tagen eben der 80. Geburtstag von dem Rudolf Cooper, der hier dieses Institut gegründet hat. Und so fühlen wir uns alle sehr wohl.
Wie viele Leute arbeiten hier in diesem Bereich?
Es waren schon mehr, aber jetzt würde ich sagen, so um die 20 Leute oder Kollegen, die hier arbeiten. Zum Teil eben Doktoranden, aber zum Teil eben auch Kollegen. Und das besondere ist, aus verschiedenen Wissenschaftsbereichen, dass wir jetzt nicht nur haben Ur- und Frühgeschichte oder nur Geologie oder nur Botanik oder nur Biologie oder nur Archäozoologie und so weiter. Sondern die sitzen eben alle hier und man sitzt hier Tür an und Tür und wenn man eben dann in seinem archäologischen Material einen Knochensplitter findet, braucht man nur eine Tür weitergehen und fragen, kannst du sagen was das ist? Und wenn dann irgendwelceh in der Keramik ein Stückchen Sediment noch übrig blieb, dann kommen die zu mir und sagen, kannst du sagen, was das ist oder aus welchem Material ist jetzt dieses alte Steinwerkzeug hergestellt worden? Und das macht eben, dass man dann Mittag immer in der großen Küche sitzt, wo früher die Müllabfuhrleute saßen, da sitzen jetzt wird und dann über alles redet und natürlich meistens über Afrika.
Also sehr interdisziplinär?
Genau.
Von seiner ganzen Anlage her?
Ganz genau.
Und so ist es auch gewünscht. Bevor wir nochmal genauer auf Ihr Forschungsthema kommen und was sich daraus auch noch alles ableiten lässt, würde mich natürlich mal interessieren, wie Sie da eigentlich hingeraten sind. Wollten Sie schon immer Forscher und Wissenschaftler werden oder eigentlich doch lieber Rockstar?
Also mein Leben ist nicht sehr linienförmig verlaufen in vieler Hinsicht. Aber was wirklich immer in eine Richtung ging, das war mein Interesse an Wüsten. Diese Begeisterung, die ich wirklich nachweislich schon als Kind hatte und ich wollte schon im Alter von 5-6 Jahren eben Archäologe in Ägypten werden.
Aber wo haben Sie denn da gewohnt?
Da haben wir in München gewohnt. Ich bin in München groß geworden.
Ja aber in München, wo entsteht denn da die Sehnsucht nach Wüste?
Es ist vielleicht als Kontrast. Es sind natürlich, also das war in der späteren Zeit, dass halt dann eben ich dann von Karl May bis Gustav Nachtigal und Heinrich Barth und die alten Forscher gelesen habe. Zum Teil in vereinfachten Versionen, dass dann die Zeit war, wo damals dieses berühmte Buch von C. W. Ceram waren oder Götter, Gräber und Gelehrte. Es waren dann später Filme, Wüstenfilme, die mich dann natürlich noch mehr dahin gelockt haben. Ich weiß nicht, wie oft ich damals den Film Lawrence von Arabien gesehen habe. Es waren auch Erzählungen meines Vaters, der ja als Journalist dann auch in den 60er Jahren viel unterwegs war, auch im Sudan zum Beispiel. Damals sogar mit dem damaligen, wenn ich mich recht erinnere, Verteidigungsminister Helmut Schmidt, der mir dann erzählt hat von der Darb el-Arbaʿīn, dieser großen alten Karawanenstrecke, die halt einstmals Südägypten mit dem nördlichen Sudan Dafour verbunden hat.
Und er hat gesagt, wenn wir dort hinziehen, weil er hatte das Angebot, dort eben mitzuhelfen, so das Radio und Rundfunk und Fernsehen aufzubauen nach der Unabhängigkeit. Und hat dann schon gesagt, um uns anzulocken, wenn wir dann nach Katum umziehen, dann kannst du jeden Tag mit dem Kamel zur Schule gehen und so weiter. Ist dann leider nichts draus geworden. Aber es sind so verschiedene Elemente, die wirklich seit Kindheit mich dahin gezogen haben und ich werde also wirklich nicht vergessen.
Also es ist schon mehr dieses Abenteuergefühl, was da so gelockt hat?
Weil ich meine die Wüste ist ja nun nicht unbedingt…
Nein.
Ja das meint man so. Also es gibt für viele Wissenschaftler, aber eben auch für Nichtwissenschaftler nichts faszinierender als die Wüste. Denn die Wüste ist halt so der Endzustand. Ich meine der ist so wie der Mars in eine Richtung, auf die wir wahrscheinlich zugehen und für einen Geowissenschaftler hat es den Vorteil, man sieht alle Ablagerungen an der Oberfläche und nicht wie hier oder auf dem Großteil der Erde, wo alles entweder von den Weltmeeren bedeckt ist oder von Vegetation, von Regenwäldern und so weiter. Von einer dicken Bodendecke. Dort liegt alles an der Oberfläche. Und das gleiche gilt zum Beispiel für die Archäologie auch. Die meiste Archäologie wird man nie hier finden und ausgraben, außer durch extrem aufwendige Ausgrabungen, wo man dann ein paar hundert Quadratmeter vielleicht mal ein paar tausend Quadratmeter ausgraben kann. In der Wüste liegt alles an der Oberfläche, und zwar so, wie es damals die prähistorischen Bewohner vor 5000-6000 Jahren zurückgelassen haben. Man findet natürlich dort auch alles, was man nie finden würde.
Seien das jetzt Meteoriten, die man an der Oberfläche sieht auf optisch reinen Flächen, wo eben die auffallen. Oder man findet eben die letzen Tiere oder Insekten, die dort bis heute überleben können. Oder die letzten Pflänzchen, die dort noch unter extremen Bedingungen bis heute zum Teil aushalten. Jetzt in absoluten zentralen Bereichen ist es völlig leblos, da gibt es auch keinen Skorpion und keine Schlange mehr und keine Termiten und keine Ameisen. Aber in den Randbereichen da findet man was. Und das liegt alles an der Oberfläche. Und es ist halt eine ewige Landschaft. Das sind biblische Landschaften und allein das Gefühl, eben dort in viele Regionen zu gehen und zu arbeiten, wo man weiß, da war noch nie ein Mensch seit die neolithische Bevölkerung da vor tausenden Jahren weggezogen ist. Wo man nicht weiß, was erwartet einen hinter der nächsten Düne, hinter der nächsten Biegung, in einem Canyon. Es ist voller Überraschungen und das ist glaube ich, wenn man eine gewisse Neugier hat an diesen Regionen, gibt es kaum was besseres.
Und natürlich diese extreme Verbundenheit halt mit der Natur, die man dort hat. Auf unseren monatelangen Forschungsaufenthalten, dort wo man halt wirklich lebt noch wie fast prähistorische Menschen, wie Nomaden, mit extrem wenigen Sachen, extrem enthaltsam, aber man ist dann verbunden. Man hat diesen 360 Grad Horizont um sich herum. Man lebt mit dem Firmament, mit den Sternen, mit den Planeten, die halt über die Nacht rüberziehen. Wir benutzen da keine Zelte, man ist sehr eng. Und das sind alles so ganz tiefe Erlebnisse, die man in dieser Weise glaube ich nur in der Wüste erleben kann. Und es ist auch kein Wunder, dass drei der größten Weltreligionen mehr oder weniger in Wüsten entstanden sind. Und also sagen wir mal, langweilige Wüste es gibt wenige. Und bei den Wüsten ist es halt so, man liebt sie oder man hasst sie, es gibt nichts dazwischen. Ja, ganz interessant, aber dann fahre ich jetzt irgendwo in die Philippinen und dann fahre ich nach Südamerika und dann komme ich wieder in die Wüste.
Ich würde sagen, entweder das oder nicht. Und für den Großteil der Menschen wahrscheinlich reicht ein Aufenthalt, dann sagen die, gut wir haben es gesehen, aber das müssen wir nicht nochmal haben. Und andere, die halt wirklich dann sich da festbeißen, die werden schon unruhig, wenn sie mal ein Jahr nicht in die Wüste kommen.
Aber wie haben Sie … gut ich sehe, das Thema war schon früher auf der Agenda, inspiriert aus verschiedensten Quellen, aber es war ja jetzt noch nicht gleich verbunden mit dem Wunsch, jetzt auch Forscher zu werden oder doch?
Nein das gar nicht. Also ich habe ja wie gesagt einen zickzackförmigen Lebenslauf gehabt. Und aber das einzige Kontinuum war, dass ich eben jedes Jahr in den Semesterferien zum Beispiel eben in die Wüste gefahren bin und das ist eben …
In den Semesterferien welchen Studiums?
Also zum Beispiel eben auch halt, dass ich einer der ersten Informatikstudenten in Deutschland war.
Damit fing es an?
Also das Studium fing an.
Also ich meine das war das erste Studium, was Sie überhaupt in Angriff genommen haben?
An der Uni schon ja genau. Aber ich wollte ursprünglich eben, ich habe das Abitur nachgemacht auf dem zweiten Bildungsweg in Berlin, andere Geschichte und war dann in Berlin und wollte eigentlich Psychologie studieren. Und da kam ich jetzt im ersten Semester nicht dran und dann habe ich mich eben nach was anderem umgeschaut, nachdem ich vorher ja über ein Jahr unterwegs war auf einer langen Reise damals, nach Indien zum Dalai Lama und sonstigen Sachen. Und habe mich dann eben entschiedne, Informatik zu studieren. Das war ein ganz neuer Studiengang.
Von welchem Jahr reden wir jetzt?
Also wir reden jetzt vom Jahr 1971/72. Wo dann an der TU Berlin ich dann durch diese Computerhallen gegangen bin, wo im Hintergrund hörte man das Sirren damals der einfachsten Maschinen, im Vergleich aus heutiger Sicht, da irgendein PDP-8 und PDP-10? Und ich hatte eigentlich von meinem familiären Hintergrund auch von meinem Interesse her überhaupt keine Vorbildung Richtung Mathematik, Richtung Informatik. Aber ich war fasziniert. Und da kam auch der Herbert W. Franke ins Spiel, zu dessen 90. Geburtstag ich vorletztes Wochenende in München war und den halte ich also wirklich für den weltbesten Science-Fiction Autor. Also von Haus aus ist er Physikprofessor gewesen. Er hat Lehrbücher geschrieben über Datierungen. Er ist Höhlenforscher. Er hat also schon in den 50er Jahren eben moderne Verfahren angewandt zur Datierung von Höhlenablagerungen.
Aber er hat eben nebenher auch ich glaube sogar … also er hat an die 50 Bücher geschrieben und die ersten Sciencefiction-Bücher damals habe ich verschlungen in den 60er Jahren, Mitte der 60er Jahre. Und die haben sicher mitgewirkt, dass praktisch ich einfach so da sehr technikbegeistert war und dann eben Informatik studiert habe, lange bevor Bill Gates und Larry Page, den ich inzwischen ja kennengelernt habe, auch über ganz andere Wege, also Jahrzehnte zum Teil vorwärts. Und ich wollte dann eben nach dem Vordiplom auch nach Berkley gehen, um dort weiter zu studieren. Ich hatte die Unterlagen ausgefüllt, meine Eltern waren einverstanden, es war wirklich die Zeit 74/75, die allerersten Anfänge im Silicon Valley und so weiter. Und wo Donald Knuth, der in Standford studiert hat, der damals der Papst der Programmierung war, Algorithmen.
Immer noch ist.
Immer noch ist. Ich habe ihn kürzlich sogar gesehen auf dem Fahrrad, als ich letztes Mal in Standford war im Dezember. Und das hat mich eben dazu gebracht, Informatik zu studieren. Aber ich bin halt trotzdem bei jeder Gelegenheit in den Semesterferien in die Wüste gefahren, und das war dann. Ich habe Informatik dann auch gemacht bis kurz vorm Hauptdiplom. Und es waren ganz wirklich hervorragende Studienbedingungen, denn das war wirklich wie nach Karlsruhe und München Ansätzen eigentlich so in Berlin waren die Anfänge. Und es gab Boolsche Benotungen, also keine Bewertungen, sondern entweder bestanden oder nicht bestanden. Es waren ganz junge Professoren natürlich. Weil es gab da ja keine Tradition darin. Und man hat da praktisch auf den ZUSE-Arbeiten aufgebaut und es war ein unglaublich faszinierendes Studium. Und bloß dann ist nach ein paar Jahren wurden diese tollen Studienbedingungen geändert. Es wurde alles formalisierter.
Es ging immer mehr in die Kerninformatik hinein, die mich jetzt nicht mehr so interessiert hatte. Und um in die Richtung zu gehen, die mich interessiert hätte, hätte ich nach Karlsruhe umziehen müssen, das wollte ich als Westberliner dann eben nicht mehr. Und so kam es eben, dass ich da dann auch aus privaten Gründen und anderen im Endeffekt nicht nach Berkley ging und dann habe ich erst mal immerhin als Informatiker teilweise auch gearbeitet jahrelang.
Aber das Studium haben Sie jetzt nicht zu Ende gemacht?
Habe ich nicht zu Ende gemacht. Ich habe nach dem Vordiplom, das hatte ich in der kürzesten Zeit, stand dann kurz vor dem Hauptdiplom und dann kamen eben private Geschichten dazu. Lange Trennung meiner langjährigen Freundin, bestimmte Bob Dylan Lieder, wo er dann in irgendeinem Song singt, „some are mathematicians, some are carpenters' wives ... I don't know what they are doing with their lives“ und ich wollte jedenfalls nicht eben dort wirklich viel verdienen vielleicht, entweder an der Uni bleiben und dann schnell in die obere Verwaltungsschiene kommen von irgendwelchen Firmen. Das wäre wirklich der Zeitpunkt gewesen. Und praktisch alle, mit denen ich damals zu tun hatte, sind dann wirklich groß ins Geschäft eingestiegen in der Informatik, die ja damals so angefangen hat, sich zu entwickeln. Und das hat mich nie interessiert. Aber die Wüsten. Und deswegen bin ich in jedem Jahr in die Wüste gefahren.
Ja also ist ja in Computerkreisen auch sehr anerkannt, wenn man ein abgebrochenes Informatikstudium vorweisen kann. Das ist ja die eigentliche Hauptqualifikation.
Und das war eben sehr lustig, als ich dann mit Larry Page bei den SciFi-Meetings, die wirklich ganz exklusive Treffen sind, wo wirklich weltweit nur 200 Leute eingeladen werden, normalerweise nur einmal. Ich hatte das Glück, mehrfach da zu sein, und dann stundenlang mit ihm zu sprechen und vielen anderen, von wirklich den führenden Köpfen an der Westküste. Und da hat sich in gewisser Weise ein Kreis geschlossen, dass ich als abgebrochener Informatikpionier oder Student zumindest für Deutschland dann an die modernen Pioniere herankam über eine ganz andere Schiene, eben dann durch mein Zweitstudium, was eben halt dann hauptsächlich die Geografie und Geologie war. Und das war auch wirklich sehr sehr lustig. Da dann viele auf diese Weise wiederzufinden.
Aber das haben Sie dann auch zu Ende gebracht?
Das habe ich natürlich zu Ende gebracht. Immer in der kürzesten Zeit, also die damals vorgegeben war. Die ja zum Glück wesentlich länger war als heutzutage, wo man erwartet, dass Studenten in drei Jahren promovieren und da würde ich sagen, zumindest in Geowissenschaften oder in Archäologie, bis auf die großen Ausnahmen, Genies vielleicht, das kann keine gute Doktorarbeit ergeben, wenn die nach drei Jahren fertig ist, da eben praktisch sowohl die Geländearbeit, die Laborarbeit, das Einarbeiten in eine Region erst mal eigentlich schon drei Jahre erfordert. Schneller geht das gar nicht. Und dann unter diesen extremen Arbeitsbedingungen, die wir halt in der Wüste haben schon gar nicht. Und dann wenn es an die Auswertung geht, und da waren das halt natürlich andere Zeiten, wo man dann erst mal als studentische Hilfskraft jahrelang sich erst in das Gebiet einarbeitet. Dann hatte man fünf Jahre eine Stelle, um seine Doktorarbeit fertig zu kriegen. Und dann hatte man nochmal fünf Jahre Perspektive auf einer ganzen Stell weiterzuarbeiten. Das war eben mein großes Glück, dass ich buchstäblich seit Studenten in gleichen Großraum der Ostsahara arbeiten kann.
Vom Student jetzt bis zu meinem Ruhestand, der im August beginnt, der natürlich nur was die Unistelle betrifft, alles andere wird ja hoffe ich noch besser weitergehen als bisher schon immer. Und so hatte ich eben das Glück, als einziger seit den späten 70er Jahren bis heute eben überwiegend über die deutsche Forschungsgemeinschaft finanzierte Großforschungsprojekte, diese Sonderforschungsbereiche eben zu arbeiten. Mit einer ähnlichen Fragestellung. Und das war für mich der Traum, der damals eben begonnen hat, als meine Wüstenbegeisterung eben auch einen beruflichen Hintergrund bekam, mit dem ich auch eben mein Leben finanzieren konnte. Und da bin ich auch gerade der deutschen Forschungsgemeinschaft auch sehr sehr dankbar für diesen Rahmen, der sich da ergeben hat.
Das heißt nach dem Studium ging es dann direkt hier nach Köln schon?
Nein überhaupt nicht. Also nachdem ich das Studium dann unterbrochen hatte, Informatik in Berlin, da habe ich in Berlin gewohnt und habe da eben gearbeitet, bin viel gereist. Alle möglichen Sachen gemacht,  nebenher auch Berliner Gruppen, die nach Berlin kamen rumgefahren. Bei den Berliner Filmfestspielen gearbeitet, gejobbt habe er als Begleiter und Fahrer und da halt wirklich alle die sogenannten oder echten Stars kennen gelernt habe auf eine sehr privaten Basis. Oder wenn irgendwelche Filmteams kamen aus den USA zum Beispiel von großen Filmgesellschaften, wie der Geraldo de Riviera, der dann kurz vor dem Kraterbesuch eben eine Reportage gemacht hat über den Drogenmissbrauch in der Berlin Brigade. Was natürlich ein heißes Thema war, wo wir dann rumgezogen sind und was manchmal wirklich auch sehr spannend dann war, da das amerikanische Militär natürlich alles gemacht hat, um das herunterzuspielen.
Umgekehrt, sie konnten sich jetzt nicht verweigern und das waren alles sehr interessante Erlebnisse. Oder mit David Bowie dann ganze Woche durch das Berliner Nachtleben zu ziehen oder dann  Robert De Niro, der dann einstieg, als ich ihn abholte am Flughafen in Tegel und der sagt, hey i’m Bob. Ich habe mich nie für Kino interessiert. Ich kannte die gar nicht. Ich habe auch nie von Scorsese gehört vorher. Der war dann in den Filmfestspielen, große Filme da. Ich glaube Raging Bull oder so, ich bin gar nicht reingegangen. und ich habe ihn dann abgeholt, wir sind dann weiter gefahren.
Nur der Partygroupie sozusagen?
Das kann man nicht sagen, weil ich variable Zeitpunkt privat hat mich das jetzt … Also waren wilde Zeiten.
Offizieller Betreuer der Stars?
Ich war bezahlt, da liegt die Uhr jede Stunde. Ich hatte Mercedes, die teuersten Limousinen zur Verfügung gestellt, auch vom Bundespräsidenten. Sie waren dann etwas lahmer,  so Mercedes 600 gepanzert. Er war dann nicht so mobil. Aber auch andere Modelle. Ich war bezahlt. Also ich hätte vielleicht die ersten ein bis zwei Jahre auch unbezahlt gemacht, so interessant war das. Aber sagen wir mal, wenn man dann gleichzeitig damit verdient und gut verdient neben her, dann war das natürlich noch besser. Und das habe ich ebenso lange gemacht, solange dann wurden die Filmfestspiele eben verlegt auf Februar und das war dann, als ich, eben Anfang der 80er, da geht es ja monatelang gerade in der Winterzeit im Gelände war, in der östlichen Sahara, damit hat sich das dann eben beendet. Weil ich eben dann Januar, Februar, März in der Wüste war und manchmal auch länger und manchmal November, Dezember, Januar, Februar.
Und dann irgendwann mal konnte ich damit auch mein Leben verdienen durch meine Arbeit. Erst als Student, dann als wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter, dann als Postdoc und das eben immer auf Unistellen und da musste ich das dann nicht mehr machen.
Das heißt die ganze Zeit für die Filmfestspiele gearbeitet, aber nie einen Film gesehen?
Genau also selten. Ich habe die Karten verschenkt. Ich war drin, ich ging raus. Das war auch manchmal, wenn Konzerte waren.
Aber es gibt auch ein paar schöne Filme auch über die Wüste.
Gibt es, aber die liegen da er nicht. Es liefern einzelne, die habe ich mir natürlich angeguckt selbstverständlich. Aber das war doch nur eher der kleinere Teil. Und dann liefen da andere Filme eben von dem Rainer Werner Fassbinder damals die ersten, den ich auch sehr gut kannte, weil ich da ja auch Ende der 60er in München mitgespielt hatte, ohne irgendwelches Talent. Aber irgendjemand war da in so einer Gruppe und dann spielte ich da eben den zweiten Polizeihund in Leonce und Lena von Büchner. Und selbst die zwei Sätze brachte ich immer durcheinander. Dagegen wurde unser Einsatz, der da einfach in dieser Zeit, wir haben manchmal vor 3-4 Leuten gespielt und nachdem die ersten bezahlt hatten, dann rief einer schnell weg, wollte noch irgendwas zu essen, damit die Mägen nicht knurrten, während den stundenlangen Ausführungen von Antigone und so weiter. Aber irgendwie kann das sehr gut an und es war einfach so eine Aufbruchstimmung, als ich noch in München war erst mal so Ende der 60er Jahre. Sowohl politisch und in jeder Hinsicht mit den Filmern damals, mit Wim Wenders, mit dem ich mich damals ständig getroffen habe und vielen anderen, die dann später große Namen wurden.
Und damals war das halt einfach so eine Avantgarde irgendwie. Und ich bin ja dann eben 1970 nach dieser langen Reise mit dem VW-Bus für 100 Deutschmark damals bis zum Dalai Lama. Vier Monate lang hat es gedauert. Was für mich so eine gewisse fast Kriegserfahrung war. Denn damals und dann mit so einem alten Auto, was jeden Tag kaputt ging, das musste man reparieren und durch Afghanistan durch und Pakistan und Indien nach Kashmir. Bis wir dann in diesem unglaublich idyllischen McLeod Ganj angekommen waren. Und damals war ja praktisch gab es also noch kaum einen, der jemals den Dalai Lama besucht hatte. Und ich bin auch nicht deswegen da hingefahren. Das war nur, dass da eben eine Mitfahrerin, die war eben in diese Richtung und die wollte unbedingt zum Dalai Lama und ihn besuchen. Und ist dann dort auch viele Monate geblieben und wir sind weitergefahren. Also ich war jetzt nicht irgendwie so spirituell interessiert. Aber es war trotzdem eine tolle Reise. Und es war ein ganz außergewöhnlicher Ort.
Weil damals da keinerlei irgendwelche anderen Ausländer waren und wir nur dorthin gekommen sind, weil einer, der dabei war, eben der hatte auch Bekannte in dem Flüchtlingsdorf, in einem tibetanischen Flüchtlingsdorf, da in dem Waisenhaus gearbeitet hat. Und so sind wir da überhaupt erst hingekommen. Und das war eben das herum, wo man dann manchmal plötzlich bei den Filmfestspielen gearbeitet hat und plötzlich war Rainer Werner der große Star auf den Filmfestspielen. Und war eine interessante Zeit, möchte ich nicht missen. Aber der Schwerpunkt war dann hat doch schon immer in der Wüste.
Die Wüste hat gerufen. Jetzt muss ich doch nochmal fragen, was sind denn so die schönsten Filme, also nicht über die Wüste, sondern gibt es Filme, wo die Wüste irgendwie eine besondere Rolle spielt und wo man auch das Gefühl hat, dass sie so als solche korrekt porträtiert wird? Ich meine das ist natürlich auch schnell Staffage, ja viel Sand, lalala.
Ja könnte ich jetzt sagen, unsere eigenen Dokus, die wir gemacht haben. In Gebieten, wo noch nie zuvor irgendein Filmteam war. Also ob das jetzt in Südostägypten war oder in Nordwestsudan oder im Nordosttschad, oder auch in dem freien Teil der Westsahara, der nicht von den Marokkanern besetzt ist und so weiter. Und da hatte ich jemals eben die ersten Filmteams dabei. Die sind natürlich auch oft nicht so gemacht, wie ich es jetzt gewollt hätte. Weil wenn dann natürlich ein Film läuft im ZDF um 19:30 Uhr beste Sendezeit am Ostersonntagabend, dann muss der natürlich für ein großes Publikum und für eine andere Zielgruppe gemacht sein. Und da habe ich auch immer praktisch den Filmmachern, den Journalisten vertraut, weil die kennen ihre Zielgruppe. Die ist jetzt nicht für einen engeren Kollegenkreis gemacht. Da wurde man dann natürlich sehr verspottet über so einen Film und so weiter.
Aber wenn dann ein anderer Film, den ich zum Beispiel in Südwestägypten gemacht habe für Arte, der kommt dann schon viel näher und ich dachte auch, der läuft einmal und nie mehr. Tatsächlich wurde der wirklich hunderte Male auch international wiederholt. Also manchmal kann man sich auch täuschen mit der Machart von Filmen, dass eben doch in Teilen der Bevölkerung Interesse besteht, auch etwas ruhiger gemachten Filmen und die dann eben nicht so abenteuerlich ausgerichtet sind, wie es jetzt wenn es für TerraX läuft oder in solchen Formaten. Aber die haben halt praktisch zumindest von den Landschaften eben schon das gezeigt und die Aspekte, die mir wichtig sind. Und zum Beispiel als Kind habe ich den Film Lawrence von Arabien mindestens 10-15 mal gesehen denke ich mal. Und ich war fasziniert von den landschaftlichen Aufnahmen und bin dann auch, eine meiner ersten Reisen haben mich gleich ins Wadi Rum geführt in Jordanien, wo ja viele der Aufnahmen gemacht wurden.
Inzwischen sehe ich den wesentlich kritischer in vieler Hinsicht. Nicht nur in historischer Hinsicht. Aber es gibt viele Filme, aber es gibt wenig Filme, die halt wirklich so das treffen, was ich immer erlebe. Und es ist dieser Film, erst mal das Buch „der englische Patient“, erschienen, da dachte ich auch, wenn ich jetzt über meine Stellen an der freien Universität Berlin das aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht mehr verlängert werde, dann werde ich mal dem Wim Wenders, den ich eben noch gut kannte aus meiner Münchner Zeit, ansprechen, dass wir da vielleicht einen Film zusammen drüber machen. Und dann war ich wieder einmal, wann war das, Mitte der 80er oder 86/87, als der Film dann rausgekommen ist.
Der englische Patient die Verfilmung dann. Weil das Buch hat mir also da meine leider früh verstorbene Schwägerin geschenkt „der englische Patient“. Ich dachte, wie kommt die darauf, dass ich jemals irgendwie Belletristik lese oder Zeit habe. Wenn dann lese ich wirklich andere Sachen, aber nicht das. Und dann blättere ich die ersten Seiten durch und sehe, das war genau das Thema. Also ein Buch, was eigentlich wir hätten schreiben müssen schon viel früher, natürlich viel besser geschrieben, ich habe das verschlungen. Ich habe es praktisch durchgelesen in einem Tag und 1,5 Nächten oder so. Und da dachte ich eben, dieser Film, der hat wirklich das Potenzial, irgendwann mal verfilmt zu werden. Aber dann war natürlich keine Gelegenheit und dann waren wir wieder an der Wahnschwimmerhöhle, die ja ganz nahe an der libyschen Grenze in Südwestägypten liegt und haben da ja mehrere Tage auch gearbeitet, ausgegraben, gearbeitet. Und diese magische Atmosphäre erfahren. Und dann kam ich zurück eben nach auch vielen Wochen oder Monaten, weiß schon nicht mehr, in der Wüste.
Der englische Patient.
Und dann kamen wir nach Kairo zurück ins deutsch archäologische Institut. Trafen dort damals den Fred Wendorf, das war damals eben der führende US-amerikanische Prähistoriker. Und der erzählte mir, der kam jetzt gerade aus Dallas und sagte, er hätte den Film schon gesehen und hat eben davon erzählt. Und dann bin ich also zurückgeflogen, wir saßen da schön abends und haben darüber gesprochen und dann kam ich zurück nach Berlin damals, und bin, bevor ich überhaupt nach Hause fuhr, sofort da in der Kantstraße in das Kino gegangen und habe mir den Film angeguckt, der lief da schon 20 Minuten, ich war zu spät, also noch mit meinen ganzen Klamotten und meinem Gepäck, was ich dann irgendwo da abgestellt hatte. Guckte den Film an und dachte, es war so frisch, also ich kam von dem wahren Drehort. Die haben natürlich das nicht dort gedreht. Der Film ist in Tunesien, in Pappmaschehöhlen zum Beispiel gedreht worden, im Studio in Hollywood, aber nie irgendwo an den Originalschauplätzen, die ja extrem schwer zugänglich sind.
Und eigentlich damals überhaupt nciht zugänglich waren. Und dann fuhr ich nach Hause, habe mich geduscht. Und am nächsten Tag habe ich mich hingesetzt, in 2-3 Stunden einen Artikel geschrieben und ich habe den dann an die Zeit geschickt und die haben sich drauf gestürzt die ganze Redaktion. In der nächsten Ausgabe war der mit einer ganzen Seite drin. Also sicher einer bis heute einer der meist gelesenen Artikel und so weiter. Hätten die es abgelehnt, wäre es auch nicht schlimm gewesen. Aber ich dachte, ich komme zurück, es ist alles noch ganz frisch. Wir haben ja diese Bezüge zurück auf den wahren englischen Patienten, eben den Laszlo Almasy und hätte ich nicht geschrieben, hätte irgendwie dazu Stellung genommen, hätte ich mich immer geärgert, aber es war natürlich schön, das es dann tatsächlich auch sofort in der nächsten Ausgabe erschienen ist, was ja oft nicht so einfach ist, gerade bei der Zeit. Und daraus haben sich dann wiederum die unglaublichsten Querverbindungen ergeben, dass zum Beispiel einer der Spione, der Hans Eppler, der ja von dem wahren englischen Patienten hinter den englischen Linien von Almashi nach Ägypten eingeschmuggelt wurde.
Und der dann relativ schnell aufflog mit seinem Funker, dem Hans Sandstede, den ich ja auch noch kennengelernt habe. Und der mich plötzlich anruft und sagt, ich habe Ihren Artikel gelesen und erzählte dann über Almashi und über die Zeit. Und irgendwann habe ich dann gesagt, ja entschuldigen Sie, sind Sie verwandt mit dem Hans Eppler, der damals von den Engländern als Spion hingerichtet wurde? Und er sagte, nein das hätten die nicht gekonnt und mein Vater war doch Richter, das haben sie sich nicht getrennt. Und der wurde in manchen Quellen damals, die ich noch hatte, da stand drin, der ist hingerichtet worden. Es gibt auch andere Bücher, wo man hätte wissen können, dass er eben doch nicht hingerichtet wurde. Und so haben sich dann viele Querverbindungen entwickelt oder zu dem Raoul Schrott, dem österreichischen Autor, der ja auch wirklich gerade dieses unglaubliche 1000 Seiten Buch veröffentlicht hat und viele andere Bücher. Und es haben sich durch diesen Artikel viele Querverbindungen gebildet, die also andauern bis zum heutigen Tag.
Wo vor zwei Tagen noch ein Ford A, dieses Modell von 1930, mit dem der englische Patient rumgefahren ist, auch die Engländer, die pionierhafte Erforschung der Frobinius-Expedition Anfang der 30er Jahre. Da dann eben Leute, die sich diese alten Fahrzeuge so wieder hergestellt haben, dass die bis heute in der Wüste einsatzfähig sind, vielleicht als einziges Fahrzeug überhaupt aus dieser Serie. Und viele andere Querverbindungen, die sich dann durch diese Medientätigkeiten, durch einen Artikel über die Jahre entwickelt haben. Und das war dann eben neben den wissenschaftlichen internationalen Kontakten so ganz andere Aspekte, die da reingerutscht sind.
Sie haben es schon erwähnt, Sie waren an einigen Dokumtarfilmen aktiv. Haben Sie die jetzt selber initiiert oder sind Sie da nur dazu geholt worden? Was waren das für Filme?
Also das war so, dass halt je mehr man Öffentlichkeitsarbeit macht, desto mehr kommt natürlich auch zurück. Und das war so, dass einer der ersten Filme eben von Arte kam, die dann von einem französischen Filmteam, die eben auch im Zusammenhang mit diesem Film „der englische Patient“ was drehen wollten. Dass gleichzeitig das ZDF kamen, die dann auch die wahre Geschichte, praktisch diesen Beitrag, den ich da für die Zeit geschrieben hatte, eben verfilmen wollten. Der dann auch an Silvester ich glaube 99 auf dem ZDF lief kurz vor Mitternacht. Eben die wahre Geschichte des englischen Patienten, das hat sicher einen großen Schub erzeugt und später kam dann von allen möglichen anderen Seiten eben Interesse und Angebote. Und ich habe das gerne gemacht, denn ich habe häufig diese Expeditionen … diese Expeditionen sind extrem aufwendig, logistisch aufwendig und auch sehr teuer.
Und oft hat da meine eigene Finanzierung, die ich hatte jetzt über die deutsche Forschungsgemeinschaft nicht ausgereicht, um wirklich in diese entlegensten Ecken, zum Beispiel des Tschad Zu kommen. Und dann habe ich gesagt, gut ihr könnt gerne mitkommen, aber ihr müsst praktisch sämtliche Kosten übernehmen. Ich habe da fast nie irgendwas verdient, aber ich habe gesagt, wenn ihr alle die Kosten abdeckt, die durch diese extrem weiten Expeditionen zustande kommen, dann betreue ich das und berate euch und mach halt alles mögliche. Besorge die Genehmigungen und so lief das auch häufig sehr gut. Dass ich wirklich mehrere Expeditionen auch komplett finanziert bekommen habe. Ja die waren sehr unterstützt in der Westsahara oder im Sudan oder in Ägypten oder im Tschad eben mehrere. Und so war das so eine Win-Win-Situation. Dass wirklich tatsächlich die Forschungsarbeit begleitet wurde und gleichzeitig ich die zusätzlichen Kosten darüber abrechnen konnte und man hat natürlich schöne Erinnerungen. Es hat natürlich einen hohen Preis.
Denn das ist jetzt nicht wie so eine BBC-Produktion, wo dann ein riesiges Filmteam ist und eine Maske und man ist jeden Abend wieder im 5-Sterne-Hotel in Tunesien und geht dann raus. Sondern dass man wirklich todmüde ist nach einem langen Fahrtag, wo man sich 50 mal festgefahren hat. Und dann immer wieder mit Sandblechen die Fahrzeuge befreien muss. Wo man also seit Wochen nicht geduscht hat. Wo man dann jeden Tag an jedem Ort gearbeitet hat bis zum Umfallen. Und dann kommt kurz vor Sonnenuntergang der Filmer, ja bitte setz dich hier hin und kommt dann mit einem Mikrofon und macht da ein Interview. Also wo man oft wirklich alles machen will als das. Aber dadurch hat es eben eine Authentizität und dann manchmal stottert man todmüde vor sich hin. Und das kann dann nicht so sein, wie in einer Produktion, wo man halt wirklich nur ein bisschen in Ägypten oder ein bisschen in Tunesien oder ganz nahe der Zivilisation arbeitet und sich dann immer wieder erst erholt und dann sich einen Text vorbereitet, den man dann da eben erzählt vor laufender Kamera.
Aber dadurch hatten eben die meisten dieser Dokumentationen, die halt wirklich auch sehr häufig wiederholt wurden, auch wirklich eine Authentizität, die oft so ist, dass sie nicht geglaubt wird. Dass dann eben vor laufender Kamera ein Motorschaden ist oder man auch vor … ich hatte in meinem ganzen Leben in diesen 60 Expeditionen nie irgendwelche Unfälle. Und die einzig beiden, die passiert sind, waren vor laufender Kamera. Vielleicht auch weil ich abgelenkt war. Wo dann zum Beispiel einmal im Sudan, wo ich sagte, wir sind jetzt müde, macht mir ein Nachtlager. Und die sagten, nein können wir nicht noch weiterfahren, es ist so gutes Licht. Und dann fährt man eben durch ein schwieriges Dünengebiet, wo man sich konzentrieren muss, denn man muss diese Barchan Dünen eben mit möglichst großer Geschwindigkeit ansteuern. Muss aber höllisch aufpassen, dass man diesen Steilhang, der auf sogenannten Slipface, auf der Leeseite, ist, schräg anschneidet, dann überschlägt sich das Auto und das war das Ende der Expedition im besten Fall. Und dann sagen die, können wir noch weiterfahren.
Und dann war der Tonmann irgendwie hinten und der Kamera mit einer kleinen Kamera und der Direktor, der Wolfgang Schiebner war dann zum Beispiel hinten im Fenster und sagt dann, ja und was ist das? Erklär mal, was sind Dünen, wann sind Sie entschieden? Und da war ich wahrscheinlich eine Sekunde abgelenkt und das erste Mal im meinem Leben bin ich dann wirklich so einen 10-12 Meter-Flug geflogen über so eine Düne, weil ich da eben nicht dann früh genug abgebogen bin und dann flogen wir durch die Luft. Wir stießen dann an auf relativ harten Boden. Dann flog dem Kameramann die Kamera aus der Hand, flog gegen die Scheibe, aber der Ton ging weiter. Oder ein anderes Mal, wo wir im Sudan fuhren, und wir fuhren plötzlich …
Hat sich der Wagen dann auch überschlagen?
Hat sich nicht überschlagen zum Glück. Aber die Scheibe war kaputt und der Motorblock war gelockert und raus. Musste dann repariert werden. Alles dann vor laufender Kamera. Ähnliche Sache ist im Tschad passiert, wo wir eben schon auf der Anfahrt fuhren noch auf der Piste, also sehr  leichtes Gelände. Und dann plötzlich war auch wieder Aufnahme, Interview. Ich fuhr mit neuen Landcruisern und plötzlich kam da ein großes riesiges Loch, wo man durchfahren konnte. Und dann war das Differenzial kaputt und wir stiegen aus. Alles vor laufender Kamera. Wo ich dann lachen musste ein bisschen. Ich dachte, das kann nicht sein, jetzt wieder das zweite Mal, zweite große Panne, die sich als sehr schwierig herausgestellt hat, vor laufender Kamera. Dann sagten die Zuschauer, ich habe ja gelacht, das war gar nicht echt. Aber es war echt. Und das führte auch dazu, dass wir dann nie mehr irgendeine Unterstützung von Toyota bekommen haben.
Weil die wollten natürlich nicht sehen, dass ein Fahrzeug auf so einer relativ leichten Strecke kaputt geht. Aber das lustigste war, oder erst mal nicht lustig war so, dass wir einmal auch, wo auch ein Fernsehteam dabei war, wir im Nordwestsudan waren. Und wir steuerten die letzte entlegene, fast unbesiedelte Oase an, El Atrun Und fuhren dann auf die zu. Und wir hatten vorher schon gefilmt mit einem großen Stativ und diese verlassene Salzarbeitersiedlung, die in El Atrun ist, wo so ein paar Leute hingehen und arbeiten, wie die Sklaven, um so ein paar Säcke mit Salz zu füllen. Was ja verschiedene gute Qualitäten hat für Kamele und auch für Menschen. Und dann eben nach dieser Knochenarbeit irgendwann das verkaufen an jemanden und dann zurückgehen. Und die war verlassen. Und dann haben eben die Filme gefilmt und dann sage ich, wir fahren weiter, weil wir weit entfernt so ein paar Menschen gesehen haben durch das Fernglas,
Und dann fuhren wir auf die mit der laufenden Kamera zu und plötzlich kommt von rechts ein Mensch mit einer Kalaschnikow, von links von allen Seiten. Dann sagte noch der Kameramann, der Erik Sick, oh mann ich habe Schiss, alles vor laufender Kamera. Wir waren plötzlich umringt. Und wir wussten ja bis zuletzt nicht, sind das jetzt irgendwelche Banditen, sind das Räuber oder im besten Fall ist es doch das offizielle sudanesische Militär, die wir dann erfuhren, eben ihren Posten leicht umgesetzt hatten. Und die dachten wiederum, wir wären jetzt irgendwelche Banditen oder Rebellen aus dem Tschad oder sonst wo her, weil die dieses große Stativ, was aufgebaut wurde, mit der großen Kamera, die dachten natürlich nicht, dass da ein Filmteam kommt, sondern das Maschinengewehr. Und im letzten Moment waren die natürlich sehr erleichtert. irgendwann erkannten sie mich auch und wir sind ausgestiegen und die Kamera lief weiter. Und so war das alles sehr authentisch.
Es war nie irgendwas gestellt. Dass man sagt, gut jetzt fahr nochmal die Düne und fahr dich fest, wie das ja oft gemacht wird in Namibia oder sonst wo. Aber es hatte auch seinen Preis, es war sehr anstrengend. Aber insgesamt hat es immer Spaß gemacht und so hat man Jahre später dann doch sehr schöne Erinnerungen an diese Expeditionen
Wie viele Filme sind in diesem Modus entstanden?
Oh müsste ich jetzt nochmal nachzählen, aber bestimmt 10. Und natürlich jetzt nicht gerechnet die ganzen Studioauftritte und Interviews oder das Material, was dann weiter verwendet wurde und jetzt eben auch für Webseiten da. Wie unsere neue Seite, eben xplore-Tschads.org, wo man dann viel von dem nicht gesendeten Material verwenden konnte und also so richtig abendfüllend oder sagen wir mal Dreiviertelstunde Dokumentation, waren schon so ca. 10.
Das ist natürlich eigentlich eine sehr glückliche Situation, wenn man seine Forschungen direkt auch gleich quasi dokumentieren kann auf so eine außergewöhnliche Art und Weise. Ich meine den Luxus haben jetzt nicht viele Forscher, dass sich direkt irgendwelche Dokumentarfilme aufdrängen und sagen, hier ich will jetzt mal mitforschen. Mag auch noch andere Gebiete geben, wo das funktioniert, aber das ist auf jeden Fall nicht die Regel. Neben den Dokumentarfilmen sind Sie ja auch an einigen Ausstellungen bereits beteiligt gewesen. So mit Fokus Klima, Naturschutz, sicherlich auch die Wüste als solches natürlich mit im Fokus. Sind dann glaube ich auch als Schreiberling immer wieder in dem Geo-Magazin zu finden. Überhaupt sehr umtriebig. Wie wichtig ist Ihnen die Medienarbeit sozusagen im Vergleich zu der eigentlichen Forschungsarbeit? Oder ist das für Sie das gleiche?
Ich würde sagen, es geht alles Hand in Hand. Also mir ist meine Forschung im Endeffekt schon das wichtigste. Einfach halt diese Neugier, die ich habe an wenig oder unerforschten Regionen. Und dann kommt halt immer dazu dieser Abenteueraspekt, der halt gerade von den Medien immer häufig mehr in den Vordergrund gestellt wird als der eigentliche Grund, der ja ist, dort zu forschen, dorthin zu kommen, dort zu forschen und eben nicht nur hinzufahren, um Abenteuer zu machen. Sondern hauptsächlich, um dort zu forschen. Und das ist ja auch nicht so, dass wie manche Wüstenfotografen, die fahren in die Wüste, um Fotos zu machen. Wir fahren nicht hin, um Fotos zu machen, sondern wir machen geologische und archäologische und andere Forschungen durchzuführen.
Aber das zu verbinden eben mit Öffentlichkeitsarbeit, dass man eben nicht nur das Zustandekommen von Forschungsergebnissen, sondern eben auch das Ganze drumherum, eben in die Öffentlichkeit bringt und damit halt wirklich buchstäblich dem Steuerzahler auch etwas direkt zurückgeht, das hat mir immer gefallen. Hat mir auch Spaß gemacht. Ich habe auch viel gelernt. Es kostet viel Extrazeit, es kostet sehr sehr viel Freizeit. Denn die normale Arbeit, die einen ja schon, die Vorbereitung der Expedition, die eigentliche Forschungsarbeit, die Auswertungsarbeit, dann das sehr mühselige Schreiben von Publikationen, da reichen ja schon 16 Stunden am Tag nicht, 7 Tage die Woche. Und wenn dann eben noch das dazukommt. Aber man kriegt eben viel zurück. Einmal dass man eben wirklich von Zuhörern von irgendwelchen Abendvorträgen oder Matineevorträgen in Deutschland, bis hin zu den Einheimischen im Tschad, die auf einen zukommen.
Und die dann sagen, Mensch wir haben dich im Fernsehen gesehen und du kennst das alles so toll und vielen Dank. Wir sind immer dankbar für die Forschungsarbeiten, für die begleitenden Naturschutzprojekte und so weiter. Und das gibt einem wiederum so viel Energie und Bestätigung zurück, dass sich da eine Eigendynamik entwickelt und dann wirklich diese drei Aspekte dann immer zusammen hat. Und sicher, die ersten Ausstellungen, die haben wir gemacht, weil wir eben da auf der Hannover Messe damals, das war schon Ende der 70er Jahre oder so, wo einfach halt schon damals so die Anfänge waren, dass halt eben diese Forschungsprojekte der
deutschen Forschungsgemeinschaft jetzt auch eben in ein breiteres Publikum gebracht werden sollten. Und dann hat sich das eben entwickelt. Dass halt dann auch eigene Ausstellungen gemacht wurden, wie zum Beispiel die Ausstellung am Ende unseres Berliner Sonderforschungsbereichs, 69 aride Gebiete, die ja dann in zig Ländern, vor allen auch Afrikas, unterwegs war über viele Jahre.
Und wo dann Eröffnungen waren überall. Ich habe zum Beispiel in Kairo gemacht und in anderen, wo dann auch wieder in den Gastländern, wo wir halt immer diese tollen Möglichkeiten hatten, eben zu arbeiten unter überwiegend optimalen Bedingungen, da in die Gastländer was zurückzugeben, außer eben ein paar Fachpublikationen und Fachaufsätze, die natürlich in den afrikanischen Ländern nur sehr sehr wenige interessieren. Wogegen eben halt so die Forschungsbedingungen, die Grundlagenforschung eben Natur- und Kulturschutzprojekte auf viel größeres Interesse stoßen als die Sachen, warum wir eigentlich in den Ländern arbeiten. Und das war so eine Wechselwirkung, dass eben wirklich diese drei Säulen also praktisch immer mir gleich viel Spaß gemacht haben.
Ja dem Stifterverband war das in diesem Jahr auch die Verleihung des Kommunikatorpreises wert. Wo diese Aspekte, die wir schon besprochen haben, eine Rolle gespielt haben, aber auch Ihr Einsatz für die Auslobung der Unesco-Weltnaturerbegebiete im Tschad zum Beispiel. Und wo noch?
Nein Welterbe das war wirklich, und das reicht ja schon für ein Leben, dass man also bis vor kurzem im viertgrößten Land Afrikas mehr und mehr mithilft, dass es seine ersten beiden Welterbestätten bekommt, und noch dazu das Ennedi-Plateau ist ja ein gemischtes Welterbe, von denen es jetzt weltweit nur 35 gibt. Und in Afrika nur 5. Also das reicht eigentlich schon für ein Leben, auch wenn ich das nächste Projekt habe und in den anderen Ländern, da waren es eben Nationalparks, wie im Sudan, wo sie halt bis heute, der Wadi Howar Nationalpark, das theoretisch zweitgrößte Naturschutzgebiet der Erde. Es weiß aber keiner. Weil der wirklich nur auf dem Papier existiert. Ist seit 2000 ausgewiesen, aber seitdem hat sich eben aufgrund der ungünstigen Umstände leider nicht viel oder so gut wie nichts getan. Aber es gibt zum Beispiel auch einen Gilf Kebir-Nationalpark in Ägypten, der bis zum Beginn der Unsicherheit, der ja inzwischen auch schon vor einigen Jahren eben immerhin doch schon ein von den Ägyptern sehr gut in Ansätzen gemanagter Nationalpark war.
Aber eben Welterbestätten, da sind die gelungenen bisher beide im Tschad.
Kommen wir doch nochmal ein bisschen auf die Wüste als solche. Jetzt haben wir quasi schon viel um den heißen Brei herumgeredet und auch sozusagen woran Sie jetzt forschen. Also eingangs hatten wir ja schon erwähnt, dass diese DFG-geförderten Sonderforschungsbereiche hier eine große Rolle spielen. Der aktuelle heißt ja, unser Weg nach Europa. Und setzt sich dann konkret mit der Frage auseinander, wie es denn dem Homo-Sapiens sozusagen gelungen ist, oder was ihn getrieben hat, von Afrika, der vermeintlichen Geburtsstätte der Menschheit, nach Europa zu ziehen. Wo ich jetzt gerade vor ein paar Tagen gelesen habe, irgendwelche Thüringer Forscher haben jetzt wieder was ganz anderes ausgegraben.
Macht mich noch etwas skeptisch, aber das ist ein anderes Thema, das geht noch viel weiter zurück.
Lassen wir das mal so als aktuellen Wissensstand im Raum stehen. Also auf jeden Fall gab es ja die Menschheit in Afrika und hat sich dort in weiten Teilen verbreitet. Was bestimmt sozusagen Ihre aktuelle Arbeit in der Hinsicht und wie kann man der Wüste solche Rätsel entlocken?
Ja wie gesagt, ich hatte eben das große Glück praktisch mein gesamtes Leben im Rahmen von Sonderforschungsbereichen leben zu können. Und da war halt erst mal in Berlin dieser große Sonderforschungsbereich 69, eigentlich das größte geowissenschaftliche Grundlagenforschungsprojekt, was meines Wissens jemals in Afrika stattgefunden hat bis heute. Und das ging eben von 1980 bis 1995. Das war aber rein geowissenschaftlich ausgerichtet. Also da ging es auch um Lagerstätten und die alte Hardrock-Geology und so weiter und die ersten Kartierungen überhaupt. Die ja dann auch mitfinanziert wurde von Erdölfirmen. Aber da kam auch ein bisschen das Quartär rein, die jüngste geologische Epoche und eben damit auch der Klimawandel, vor allem in den letzten 10-12.000 Jahren. Daran anschließend kam er dann nach Köln.
Das war auch der Grund, warum ich dann nach 1995 in den Kölner Sonderforschungsbereich Acacia Gegangen bin. Der hatte dann eben einerseits diese Klimaperspektive, aber anderseits eben auch die Besiedlungsgeschichte und die prähistorische Entwicklung wieder im gleichen Raum, eben hauptsächlich Ägypten und Sudan und dann kam eben auch etwas Libyen und Tschad dazu. Und da war dann eben diese Komponente des Menschen dabei. Und das macht es halt ganz ganz ganz spannend. Weil reine Klimaforschung ist interessant, aber Bedeutung bekommt sie eben erst, wenn der Mensch dabei ist. Deswegen sage ich ja immer, die Eisforschung, also die in den Polargebieten, in Grönland, in der Antarktis ist hoch interessant. Aber es ist nun kein Lebensraum des Menschen. Und das gleiche gilt für die Marineforschung. Die ja unglaublich wichtig ist, weil dort natürlich tolle Ablagerungsbedingungen sind und man kann da viele Bohrkerne ziehen. Aber der Mensch ist nunmal weder Pinguin noch Fisch.
Sondern Mensch lebt auf den bewohnbaren Kontinenten. Und dafür braucht man terrestrische Paläoklimatologie und die kann man eben nur da machen, wo Menschen noch heute leben oder auf den Kontinenten oder wo sie mal gelebt haben, als andere Klimabedingungen waren. Und der Mensch ist ja ein sehr sensitiver Klimaanzeiger. Das heißt man kann den Menschen und gerade in solchen natürlichen Laboratorien, wie der östlichen Sahara, die ja hauptsächlich die ägyptische Wüste und die nordsudanesische Wüste umfasst, was relativ flach ist, wo es keine Gebirge gibt, wo die Küsten sehr weit entfernt ist. Das ist also ein relativ flacher Siedlungsraum. Und da kann man eben den Klimawandel in den letzten vor allem 11.000 Jahren hervorragend nachvollziehen und rekonstruieren nur dadurch, dass man eben sieht, zu welcher Zeit waren wo prähistorische Siedlungsplätze. Denn dort ging es jetzt nicht wie in vielen anderen Regionen der Erde, wo es ein bisschen mehr geregnet hat, ein bisschen weniger geregnet hat, was sehr schwer praktisch zu rekonstruieren ist nach Jahrtausenden.
In der Ostsahara war es so, solange es geregnet hat, gab es Vegetation, es gab Wildtiere und die Menschen konnten dort siedeln. Sobald der Regen weniger wurde und aufgehört hat, dann hatten sie keine Wahl. Entweder sie blieben und haben vielleicht noch ein paar Jahrhundert ausgehalten, dadurch dass sie immer tiefere Brunnen gebohrt haben. Aber wenn dann das Grundwasser zu niedrig gefallen war, dann hatten sie nur noch die Wahl zu bleiben und zu verdursten oder weiterzuziehen. Und das haben sie eben auch gemacht über die Jahrtausende. Dass man eben sieht, dass es eben mal eine Zeit gab vor 8.000 Jahren, wo fast die gesamte Sahara besiedelt war und dann setzte eben vor rund 6.000 Jahren die Austrocknung an, die sich über Jahrtausende hingezogen hat und dann sind die Menschen ganz langsam, was heute Südwestägypten ist, immer weiter nach Süden gezogen. Immer weiter nach Süden, bis sie dann schließlich angekommen sind, wo sie heute noch leben. Also in der Sahel-Zone.
Und deswegen ist es eben der prähistorische Mensch ein sehr guter Klimaanzeiger. Und gleichzeitig sieht man eben die Auswirkungen von Klima und Umweltwandel auf die Menschen, also ich würde sagen, fast besser als irgendwo sonst. Und das war halt immer der interessante Aspekt durch diese interdisziplinäre Fragestellung. Und jetzt ist durch den laufenden Sonderforschungsbereich 806 eben unser Weg nach Europa, die Wanderung des anatomisch modernen Menschen, aus den ältesten Fundstellen, die man zumindest bis heute kennt. Die eben so im südlichen Äthiopien in diesem Raum Ostafrikas liegen, bis zu uns hier nach Zentraleuropa und auch noch weiter, aber vor allem eben bis hierhin. Dass da jetzt noch diese Zeitschiene der letzten 10.000 Jahre, die in den vorhergehenden zwei Sonderforschungsbereichen im Mittelpunkt steht eben noch aus in die ältere Vergangenheit, also in die vorhergehende Feuchtzeit.
Die eben während des Eem stattgefunden hat, eben so vor rund 120.000 Jahren. Und das hat dann eine thematische und chronologische Erweiterung dieser älteren Fragestellungen und das ist einfach ein großes Glück, wenn man die eben alle so erleben durfte.
Wie muss man sich denn die Wüste, die Sahara, vorstellen vor 8.000 Jahren. Also wenn das dann erst so ausgetrocknet ist, was war denn da vorher? War das so wie Italien oder?
Ja jetzt nicht unbedingt wie Italien. Aber man könnte schon sagen zum Beispiel, es sah aus wie in einem heutigen relativ naturbelassenen Nationalpark sagen wir mal im nördlichen Kenya. Wo eben die gesamte Tierwelt, die wir ja gefunden haben als Knochen, aber auch natürlich in Felsbilddarstellungen, von denen es ja abertausende überall gibt, und vor allem eben jetzt auch im nördlichen Tschad, wo ein Großteil ja bis vor kurzem ja noch gar nicht so bekannt war. Und die eben zeigen Elefanten und Nashörner und Giraffen und Antilopen. Und später kamen dann die Rinder dazu und erst vor 2.000 Jahren die Kamele. Also es war wirklich ein Lebensraum, der aussah wie eine entwickelte Savanne und diese entwickelte Savanne ist ja weitgehend verschwunden durch die menschliche Nutzung in den letzten tausend Jahren und da muss man eben da noch in Nationalparks gehen, wo wenigstens noch ein Großteil der Vegetation ungefähr so aussieht wie damals.
Und dann hat man ein Bild von der Hochzeit, dem Höhepunkt der letzten Feuchtzeit in der Sahara. Und vor 120.000 Jahren diese Feuchtzeit war höchstwahrscheinlich noch länger und noch ausgeprägter als heute, da gab es also noch größere Seen und noch mehr Flüsse und sicher noch eine üppigere Fauna und Flora als eben bis vor rund 5.000 Jahren. Aber das war ein idealer Lebensraum, auch gerade für den prähistorischen Menschen. Da das ja die Umwelt war, die er kannte, als die Sahara noch eine undurchquerbare riesige Wüste war eben von der Dimension der USA, die nicht zu queren war und schon gar nicht zu einer Zeit, als es noch keine Kamele gab und auch keine Esel. Und dann hat sich eben diese Wüste relativ schnell, aber trotzdem über mindestens 1000 Jahre zu einer Savanne entwickelt.
Die halt im Süden mehr eine Baumsavanne war, in dem zentralen Teil mehr eine Grassavanne, aber sie wurde grün. Also dieser Ausdruck der grünen Sahara ist nicht falsch. Und die Niederschläge, die Monsunregen sind immer weiter vorgedrungen ins Innere der Sahara und dann paar hundert Jahre später sind dann die Menschen denen gefolgt, um zu jagen, um zu sammeln, um dort zu leben, um dort zu fischen und die sind dann dort solange geblieben, bis dann eben diese Austrocknung vor rund 6.000 Jahren angefangen hat, und dann sind sie eben praktisch überwiegend wieder dahin zurückgezogen, in die Regionen, aus denen sie gekommen sind. Und das kann man eben an der Sahara direkter und anschaulicher nachvollziehen als würde ich sagen fast in irgendeinem anderem Landschafts- und Klimaraum auf der Erde. Und dieser Vorgang hat sich sicher mehrfach wiederholt.
Weil es ja etwa alle 100.000 Jahre ein paar tausend Jahre Feuchtzeit und da wurde die Sahara dann auch besiedelt und auch wie in den früheren Perioden, vor 100.000-500.000 Jahre, wo die Bevölkerungsdichte natürlich noch viel extrem geringer war als vor 10.000 Jahren, von heute reden wir gar nicht mehr. Oder so in der Sahelzone. Und das lässt sich eben gerade in der Ostsahara, die eben nicht gestört ist durch Gebirge und andere Einflüsse eben sehr sehr gut nachvollziehen.
Was war der Auslöser für diesen Klimawandel.
Also der Klimawandel ist natürlich … ich bin ja im Grunde Feldforscher, ich bin Quartärgeologe, Klimaforscher, so ein angelernter halber Archäologe, aber das Entscheidende ist sagen wir mal, es ist praktisch eine allgemein akzeptierte Tatsache, dass diese zyklischen Feuchtzeiten in der Sahara genauso wie die Kaltzeiten oder die Eiszeiten bei uns und die Eisbedeckung eben durch astronomische Faktoren zustande gekommen sind. Die eben in den Erdbahnelementen der Erde um die Sonne liegen. Die sich eben nach den sogenannten Milankovic-Kurven ändern in verschiedenen Zyklen. Und was ich in der Sahara am besten nachvollziehen kann oder wo es die meisten Hinweise gibt, dass es eben wirklich so rund alle 100.000 Jahre eben von dem zustand gelb in den Zustand grün ging und zurück. Und dass die anderen Zyklen, die es auch gibt, zum Beispiel wie der 42.000 Jahre Zyklus, dass es dafür keine Hinweise gibt.
Also entscheidend ist wahrscheinlich der Zeitpunkt, wann die höchste Insulation, die höchste Einstrahlung, in welcher Jahreszeit, die die heutige Breitenzone der Sahara erfasst. Also es liegt in dem Abstand zur Sonne. Und in den Bewegungen der Erde um die Sonne. Heute sind wir vielleicht eben an diesem historischen Zeitpunkt angelangt, dass der jetzige Klimawandel zum ersten Mal eben halt nicht durch die astronomischen Faktoren bedingt ist, sondern durch den Menschen selbst. Und dass es dadurch vielleicht jetzt wieder zu einer Klimaveränderung kommt, wie in der bisherigen gesamten Vergangenheit der Menschheitsgeschichte nur durch eben natürliche Faktoren. Und das ist natürlich ein sehr spannender Aspekt und ein sehr umstrittener Aspekt auch.
Weil was ich sehe und vermute ist eben, dass die globale Erwärmung für eine Region wie die Sahara, die ja die Dimension hat der USA, und wenn man sie in den altweltlichen Trockengürtel vom Atlantik bis ins zentrale China, Asien hinein erweitert, dann ist es ja ein noch viel größerer Raum und dass da eine globale Erwärmung durchaus auch positive Aspekte haben könnte. Denn eine Sache wissen wir ganz genau, da lässt sich nicht diskutieren, das sind wirklich feste geologische, archäologische Belege, dass am Ende der letzten Kaltzeit aufgrund als Faktor der globalen Erwärmung praktisch die globale Temperatur gestiegen ist. Dadurch wurden die Weltmeere, jetzt etwas vereinfacht ausgedrückt, haben sich erwärmt, dadurch gab es eine größere Verdunstung über den Weltmeeren, die Monsunzirkulation hat sich verstärkt und dadurch wurde durch die Monsunwinde eben diese Feuchtigkeit von den Ozeanen viel weiter in das Innere der Kontinente verfrachtet und ganz speziell eben in die Sahara hinein.
Und die Niederschläge haben sich so lange verstärkt, bis sich die Vegetation dort ausbreiten konnte und so weiter. Und da leuchtet mir nicht ein, warum sich dieser belegbare Klimawandel jetzt nicht wiederholen sollte, weil wenn die Auswirkungen die gleichen sind, die Ursachen sind verschieden, da gibt es auch unterschiedliche Modellierungen, manche, die dafür sprechen, manche, die eher dagegensprechen, bloß ich vertraue halt der Geologie, und den Sachen, die man wirklich als Ablagerungen findet, untersuchen kann, datieren kann und damit weiß, es gab vor 12.000 Jahren keinen einzigen See in der Sahara und nach 11.000 vor heute gab es abertausende überall, riesige Seengebiete und Flüsse. Und dann ist der Niederschlag ausgeblieben und es wurde wieder trocken.
Und wenn so etwas wiederkäme, dann wäre das natürlich durchaus bei allen negativen Auswirkungen des menschgemachten Klimawandels wäre das eine positive Zukunftsaussicht.
Also für die Wüste?
Für die Wüste, für die Sahara, die immerhin ein Drittel des afrikanischen Kontinents einnimmt, 10 Millionen Quadratmeter von 30 Millionen Quadratkilometern, und das wäre ja ein nicht zu unterschätzender Vorteil, wenn praktisch ein Drittel des Kontinents wieder bewohnbar wäre. Aber wie gesagt, so schnell geht es nicht, so schnell ging es auch in der Vergangenheit nicht. Und in ein paar hundert Jahren werden wir nicht mehr leben, um zu sehen, welche Vorhersage jetzt eingetreten ist.
Naja deswegen nehmen wir ja diesen Podcast auf, weil der wird das auf jeden Fall überleben. Wenn jetzt sozusagen dieser Klimawandel den Homo Sapiens wieder da hingeschickt hat, wo er herkam. Er kam ja nciht aus Europa. Oder vielleicht kam er doch aus Europa und er ist sozusagen nur wieder zurückgegangen, gibt es denn da schon Antworten?
Es gibt nur Hypothesen. Man muss sich überlegen, einmal sind wir jetzt über das Holozän, also praktisch die jüngste Zeit seit der letzten Kaltphase, dieses Interglacial, also das umfasst hier also gerade in der Sahara jetzt nur die letzten 11.000 Jahre. Und da wissen wir schon relativ gut bescheid. Für die vorhergehende eben grüne Sahara vor sagen wir mal gut 100.000 Jahren, da wissen wir viel viel weniger. Wir wissen vielleicht nicht ein Promille der Daten und Proben, die wir haben, für die jüngste Feuchtphase, haben wir für die vorhergehende, die noch vorhergehende noch weniger, und so geht das weiter. Und die Bedeutung der Arbeit oder sagen wir auch meinen Arbeiten oder der Kollegen in der Sahara, da geht es ja jetzt nicht drum über die Herkunft, sondern es geht nur drum, war die Sahara ein Korridor, ein grüner Korridor, durch den der prähistorische Mensch unsere genetischen Vorfahren eben wandern konnte oder nicht.
Das ist die entscheidende Frage. Und die Herkunft ist unabhängig. Und da ist jetzt natürlich bis heute eine große Diskussion, wie weit war das Klima dafür verantwortlich, dass es überhaupt zu diesem großen Evolutionssprung gekommen ist. Und das kann man sehr diskutieren. Tatsache ist, dass diese ganzen Knochen der alten Huminiden, also die allerersten unserer Vorfahren, die ja vor über 7 Millionen Jahre offenbar in dem nördlichen Tschad gelebt haben, diese ganzen Knochen passen in einen Koffer. Und die Knochen lassen sich nur extrem schwierig bis gar nicht oder nur indirekt datieren, mit riesigen Unsicherheiten, die 100.000 Jahre wenn nicht Millionen Jahre umfassen können. Also man sollte sehr sehr vorsichtig sein. Ich denke, es ist legitim, Hypothesen aufzustellen und die zu begründen. aber zu sagen, das ist jetzt die Wahrheit, das halte ich für unseriös für jeden Wissenschaftler.
Denn es ist immer nur das beste, was man zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt aufgrund seiner Arbeiten der Allgemeinheit ausdrücken kann. Und da geht es jetzt drum, war die Sahara grün, so dass man durchlaufen konnte auch ohne Kamele. Und da bin ich schon überzeugt, dass das vor 120.000 Jahren möglich war und das wäre dann ein zeitliches Fenster gewesen, wo die prähistorischen, also die modernen, anatomisch modernen Menschen aus Südäthiopien dann durchlaufen konnten. Und zwar nicht nur Richtung Südwestasien, unserem nahen Osten, über die Türkei, Bulgarien nach Zentraleuropa. Sondern eben auch die andere Richtung in den Maghreb nach Nordwestafrika, das heutige Marokko und Algerien und dann über die Gibraltar-Meeresenge nach Spanien. Dass das also wirklich kein Korridor mehr war. Dann kann man natürlich sagen, warum sind diese frühen Menschen nicht einfach dem Nil entlanggelaufen. Ich glaube schon deswegen, weil eben diese Menschen waren Savannenbewohner.
Die waren vertraut mit einer offenen Baumsavanne, mit einer Grassavanne, mit den Tieren. Das waren Jäger, die waren dort. Das waren keine Dschungelbewohner, die sich dann da von Krankheiten und Krokodilen und Flusspferden verseuchten Tal entlang durchgeschlagen haben mit einer Machete, die es damals gar nicht gab. Also ich würde sagen, man bleibt in dem vertrauten Lebensraum mit seinem Knowhow, mit seiner Lebens- und Wirtschaftsweise. Und das ist für mich viel naheliegender, dass sie eben wirklich zu einem Zeitpunkt durch die Sahara gezogen sind. Und die anderen Hypothesen, dass sie eben über dieses Rote Meer gezogen sind, dann über den persischen Golf wieder gezogen sind und dann außen rum, das erscheint mir nicht plausibel. Und ich glaube, man wird noch lange lange arbeiten müssen, um jetzt halbwegs verlässliche Grundlagen zu haben. Um zu sagen, gut der Mensch ist nicht entlang des Nils, er ist nicht durch die Sahara gezogen, sondern ist eben wirklich über zwei Meere irgendwie rübergekommen.
Dann hat die ganze saudiarabische Halbinsel überquert und ist dann eine riesigen Umweg über Persien nach Europa gekommen. Also leuchtet mir zumindest nicht ein, aber ich kann eben nur dazu Stellung nehmen, wann war die Sahara eine Wüste? Und das war 90% in den letzten Millionen Jahren mindestens. Und nur immer in relativ kurzen Intervallen war sie grün. Und das würde ja chronologisch auch ganz gut passen, wenn man eben vor gut 100.000 Jahren die Sahara queren konnte und damit sich auf den Weg nach Europa zu machen.
Sie sagten vorhin, es gab zu einer bestimmten Zeit noch keine Kamele, aber wohl die anderen Tiere. Wo kamen denn die Kamele dann auf einmal her?
Nein die Kamele wurden ja erst vor gut 2.000 Jahren von den Persern eingeführt nach Nordägypten und dann hat es halt nach allem was wir wissen, dem wenigen was wir wissen, schon relativ lang gebraucht, bis sich die Kamele dann auch über die ganze Sahara verbreitet haben. Also das ging nicht in paar Jahrzehnten, sondern über viele hundert Jahre.
Aber das ist ein menschlicher Import sozusagen?
Menschlicher Import eindeutig durch die Perser.
Okay, aber fühlen sich da ganz wohl die Kamele eigentlich?
Die fühlen sich sehr wohl. Außer in der richtigen Ostsahara, also in unseren Hauptarbeitsgebieten, wo es eben so trocken ist, dass dort auch keine Kamele überleben können, weil es gibt keine Wasserstellen und damit gibt es eben auch keine Nomaden, wie in der zentralen und westlichen Sahara.
Ja die östliche Sahara, das ist ja so Ihr Fokus. Die sich von der westlichen Sahara nochmal dadurch unterscheidet, dass sie quasi nochmal lebensfeindlicher ist als alles andere. Wie trocken muss man sich das vorstellen?
Auf jeden Fall. Es ist, auch wenn man manchmal liest, die Antarktis wäre noch trockener, aber wenn man eben genau das nachmisst, ist die östliche Sahara, die eben praktisch so in Ägypten, nördlichen Sudan und nördlichen Tschad und eben südöstlichen Libyen, liegt, ist das der größter hyperaride Raum der Erde. Das heißt es ist eine riesige Region, die insgesamt ebenfalls zwei Millionen Quadratkilometer groß ist, wo in der Kernzone praktisch kein Niederschlag ist oder es sind vielleicht langjährig im Mittel eben zwei Millimeter Niederschlag gegen eine Verdunstung von über 6.000 Millimetern. Das heißt es würde 3.000 mal mehr verdunsten als an Niederschlag fällt. Und zwei Millimeter sind ja nur ein paar Tröpfchen im Vergleich. Also zu irgendeiner deutschen Stadt, die 600-800 Millimeter pro Jahr hat, das sin zwei Millimeter und in einem Gebiet, wo es das ganze Jahr über, eben bis auf ein paar Wintermonate extrem heiß ist.
Wo die Verdunstung groß ist. Also das heißt es ist praktisch regenlos. Und selbst das bisschen Regen, der manchmal fällt, der reicht nicht mal an die Oberfläche. Man sieht ihn noch, aber verdunstet, bevor er dann auf den heißen Boden fällt. Und damit ist es halt wirklich die trockenste Region. Und wenn es überhaupt kein Wasser mehr gibt, dann gibt es auch kein Leben. Und es gibt riesige Gebiete, wo Sie wirklich hunderte Kilometer fahren können, es gibt natürlich keine Menschen, es gibt keine Pisten. Es gibt auch keine Oase, wo Sie fahren, ohne irgendein Lebenszeichen zu finden, also auch kein Skorpion und keine Schlange. Und nicht mal eine Grünalge. Und erst je weiter man dann eben aus dieser Kernzone nach Norden Richtung Mittelmeer geht oder weiter in den Süden, Richtung Sahel-Zone, subsaharisches Afrika, da nimmt dann eben sowohl die Vegetation wie die Fauna zu. Bis dann endlich auch die allerersten Siedlungen kommen, aber das ist erst sehr weit im Süden.
Warum ist es denn da überhaupt so trocken? Also ich meine, das ist ja jetzt gut, da ist es schon warm, keine Frage, nördlicher Wendekreis ungefähr. Aber wenn man jetzt den Globus ein wenig dreht, dann ist das so die selbe Ebene wie Nordindien und Teile Chinas etc., wo ja all diese ganzen Trockenheitszonen so nicht existieren. Was macht diese Region so trocken?
Also es gibt ja mehrere Wüstentypen, die vorkommen. Wie die Atacama, die auch sehr trocken ist, aber nur existiert durch den Humboldt-Strom und durch die kalten Meeresgewässer und Strömungen und so weiter. Aber die Sahara als wirklich größte und dominierende und vielfältigste Wüste der Erde, das ist eben eine typische Wendekreiswüste, wo eben aufgrund der atmosphärischen Zirkulation und die Passatwinde eben praktisch die Niederschläge verhindert werden und die Verdunstung sehr groß ist und das ist eben die Besonderheit, dass praktisch der afrikanische Kontinent ja wirklich mehr als die Hälfte unter dem heutigen Wendekreis liegt. Und dass deswegen zum Beispiel, wäre der afrikanische Kontinent auf den Kopf gestellt, dann wäre die Sahara viel kleiner.
Und das ist also ein Zusammenspiel von der Form des afrikanischen Kontinents und gleichzeitig eben der Funktion als Wendekreiswüste, dass wir eben diese riesige Wüste haben, die an die 10 Millionen Quadratkilometer groß ist.
Wenn man da jetzt eine Expedition hinmacht, an so einen Ort, was muss man denn da … also wie muss man sich denn drauf vorbereiten einerseits, also woran muss man überhaupt denken? Können Sie mal einen Ablauf so einer Reise mal grob skizzieren?
Es sind sehr sehr aufwendige Unternehmungen. Früher gingen ja die Expeditionen 2-6 Monate lang und man muss praktisch für diese Monate, die man in der völlig menschenleeren Wüste dann verbringt, alles mitnehmen, was man braucht. Und wenn man jetzt so eine Gruppe hat von 10 Menschen. Man muss also jeden Tag 5 Liter Wasser mitnehmen, die wir immer so im Schnitt gerechnet haben. Oft haben wir sie nicht gebraucht. Und für alles, für Trinken, Kochen, Waschen, Zähneputzen und so weiter, also 5 Liter im Mittel. Dann braucht man natürlich Notreserven. Man muss sämtlichen Treibstoff mitbringen. Wir hatten zum Teil 26 Tonnen, mehrere Unimogs und dann noch 5-6 von Geländewagen, die den gesamten Treibstoff für viele Monate für tausende Kilometer lange Anfahrten und Rückfahrten natürlich. Wir hatten zum Beispiel bei einem Berliner Projekt einen eigenen Tankwagen, in den fast 10.000 Liter Diesel und und nochmal 6.000 Liter Wasser reingepasst haben.
Die man braucht. Man muss sämtliche Lebensmittel mitnehmen. Man muss natürlich medizinische Versorgung mitnehmen. Man muss Werkzeug mitnehmen und so weiter. Und dann kommt ja erst drauf die wissenschaftliche Ausrüstung, die man braucht zur Probennahme, für Bohrungen, für alle möglichen sonstigen Untersuchungen und Vermessungen. Es ist eine wirklich immer so eine gerade monatelangen Unternehmungen, das sind wirklich so kleine militärische Aktionen. Wo man alles mitnehmen kann. Und alles was man nicht dabei hat, ist nicht ersetzbar. Und jedes Satellitentelefon, was man jetzt hat, was ausfällt, ist unersetzbar. Jedes Messgerät, das unter den extrem harten Bedingungen eine kleinere Reparatur erfordert, wo man hier mal in den Baumarkt fährt, und man geht in die Werkstatt und lässt es reparieren, ist dann nutzlos für den Rest des Aufenthalts.
Und man muss eben sagen, also ich sage immer wirklich, die Wüste frisst alles. Es gibt kaum etwas, was in der Wüste diese harten Bedingungen von den Temperaturschwankungen eben am Tag bis 50 Grad im Schatten, bloß Schatten gibt es ja nicht, es sind ja viel höhere Temperaturen, nachts kann es bis weit unter 0 Grad runtergehen. Die Sandstürme, die Staubstürme, der Staub, der überall reingeht wie Wasser. Und gerade sind da elektronische Geräte extrem anfällig und Kameras und so weiter. Also es ist nur eine Frage der Zeit, bis fast alles kaputt geht. Das ist jetzt ein Aspekt, eben dieser riesige logistische Aufwand, der für jeden Geländeeinsatz wirklich nicht nur Wochen, sondern meistens monatelange Vorbereitung erfordert. Dann sind es die allgemeinen Lebensbedingungen. Wo ich sagen würde, das würden viele Soldaten auf die Dauer nicht mitmachen. Denn man muss überlegen, man ist mehrere Monate unterwegs. Man schläft immer draußen am Boden.
Vielleicht auf einer Isomatte in seinem Schlafsack. Wir haben fast nie Zelte dabei aus verschiedenen Gründen, weil sie entweder wegfliegen oder die ganze Nacht flattern im Wind oder weil man sie überhaupt nicht richtig fixieren kann im Boden. Oder weil die Luftfeuchtigkeit, die sich im Zelt entwickelt in kalten Nächten die Kälte noch verstärkt und so weiter. Also man schläft draußen, man lebt von 5 Litern bestenfalls am Tag. Man isst sehr eintönig. Normalerweise einen Abend Reis, nächsten Abend Nudeln, am nächsten Tag Reis, Nudeln und so weiter mit einer einfachen Soße aus Konserven und vielleicht noch ein paar Zwiebeln natürlich, die man mitnehmen kann. Beim Frühstück entweder Müsli oder Dosenbrot. Man isst mittags paar Fischdosen. Es gibt keinerlei Ablenkung. Man hat also da manchmal monatelang kein Bier natürlich, keinen Schluck Alkohol. Man kann nicht mal ins Kino gehen, man kann sich nicht duschen. De facto sind es wirklich Lebensbedingungen, wo man wirklich schon hochmotiviert sein muss, um die zu akzeptieren.
Und das ist auch ein Problem, dass es immer schwieriger wird, eben auch Studenten zu finden oder überhaupt Kollegen, die bereit sind, unter diesen Bedingungen regelmäßig in die Wüste zu fahren. Und da sind wir wirklich so eine aussterbende Generation glaube ich. Und dann kommt natürlich in der jüngeren Vergangenheit, also in den letzten 10 Jahren diese wachsende Unsicherheit hinzu, die ja praktisch jetzt fast die gesamte Sahara erfasst, eben durch Terrorismus, durch die Verfügbarkeit von kleinen Waffen, natürlich auch durch moderne Navigationsmittel wie GPS oder andere, die es viel einfacher machen, in entlegene Regionen zu fahren. Was früher ja gar nicht möglich war. Da ist man aus dem letzten Oase rausgefahren und man wusste, niemand würde einen jemals finden. Auch keine größere Armee. Außer die würden jetzt Satellitenüberwachung machen und so weiter.
Dagegen heutzutage, jeder der einen guten Geländewagen hat und ein GPS, der könnte sich auf unsere Spuren machen. Und diese Unsicherheit ist vielleicht wirklich auch das schlimmste neben den Landminen, die halt wirklich noch in manchen Gebieten, natürlich immer nur auf den Hauptachsen als Hinterlassenschaften des Zweiten Weltkriegs in manchen Regionen, in Ägypten zum Beispiel und Libyen oder jetzt auch im Tschad, die dann auf die kriegerische Auseinandersetzungen damals zwischen Tschad und Libyen zurückgehen. Dass man dann auf der Anfahrt vor allem aufpassen muss, dass man nicht irgendwie auf eine alte Mine fährt, die sich ja in diesem sehr trockenen Milieu sehr lange halten. Wenn man dann mal richtig weit weg ist und in richtigen Arbeitsgebieten, da war nie jemand und da ist auch nichts zu befürchten. Aber man muss ja immer erst mal hin und zurückkommen und das ist eben dieser neue Aspekt, der es sicher so schwierig gemacht hat, in der Sahara zu arbeiten, wie nie zuvor.
Und dass selbst die Altvorderen, die jetzt so vor 80 Jahren dort geforscht haben oder die allerersten von 150 Jahren, wie Gerhard Rohlfs in Ägypten zum Beispiel, diese Probleme hatten die nicht. Und die hatten die völlige Unterstützung jetzt eben halt von damaligen Königen oder von der Regierung. Die hatten ihre bewaffneten Bewacher dabei. Und hatten also eher günstigere Bedingungen als wir die heute haben. Und sie hatten eben bis in die 30er Jahre hinein und zum Teil bis in die 50er Jahre hinein halt Expeditionen, die halt dann mit Kamelen durchgeführt wurden. Die also weniger reparaturanfällig sind als Fahrzeuge. Wo halt heute gerade bei den modernen Fahrzeugen, wenn da irgendeine Elektronik ausfällt, dann muss man das Fahrzeug stehen lassen und wenn ein Kamel stirbt, ist traurig und schlimm, aber man kann weiterziehen, wenn man genug dabei hat. Also es ist heute in vieler Hinsicht eher schwieriger geworden. Und das schreckt eben halt immer mehr ab.
Und das muss man eben auch sehen, dass die Rahmenbedingungen, unter denen wir diese Proben nehmen, die ja zum Teil ganz tolle Ergebnisse gebracht haben, die unvergleichbar schwieriger sind, als wenn man jetzt
auf einem Forschungsschiff unterwegs ist, wo Bohrarbeiter die Kerne ziehen. Man hat schon Laboratorien auf den Forschungsschiffen, man lebt in einem klimatisierten Raum. Und selbst auf Grönland, wo man dann meistens den ganzen Tag, wenn man drin ist, in Shorts verbringt und nicht unter diesen prekären Bedingungen, die wir haben. Und jede Probe, die wir dort nehmen, die müssen wir dann erst mal tausende Kilometer ohne irgendwelche Straßen oder Pistenverbindungen zum Teil zurück bringen in die Hauptstädte. Da müssen wir die exportieren und zurückbringen. Also der Aufwand ist erheblich. Und deswegen hat es auch in der Ostsahara kaum jemand gemacht sage ich jetzt mal, außer unseren deutschen Forschungsprojekten im Rahmen dieser Sonderforschungsbereiche in Berlin und Köln. Also vergleichbares gibt es nicht.
Jetzt schon überhaupt nicht mehr, weil in dieser riesigen Wüste ja praktisch überhaupt niemand mehr arbeitet, sagen wir mal außer uns. Und eben auch früher gab es nie vergleichbare Projekte, die eben halt diesen riesigen logistischen Aufwand erfordern, diese Einsatzfreude, diese monatelangen Geländeaufenthalte. Wenn man es mag, ist es ein Traum. Aber für die meisten Wissenschaftler, die jetzt mehr ergebnisorientiert arbeiten wollen und die wollen nur Proben holen, da macht man es einmal mit zweimal, wenn es hochkommt und dann möglichst nie wieder. Und das erfordert eben schon mehrere günstige Faktoren, sonst würde man nie eben dieses Probenmaterial und diese Daten bekommen.
Die ESA zum Beispiel betreibt ja großen Aufwand, um kleinere Gruppen von Leuten in der Antarktis für ein paar Monate wegzuschließen. Verspricht sich davon vor allem psychologische Erkenntnisse. Was für psychologische Erkenntnisse haben Sie denn aus diesen Expeditionen gezogen? Weil wenn man jetzt wirklich mehrere Monate in so einem eingeschränkten Personenkreis unter solchen extremen Bedingungen ist, wo jeder ja wahrscheinlich an irgendeinem Tag irgendein Zipperlein ausbrütet, geht man sich dann nicht irgendwann an die Gurgel?
Ohja, ein ganz wichtiger Aspekt, eben diese Gruppendynamik auf Expeditionen. Und das ist ja durchaus vergleichbar. Wir sind ja auch fast wie auf einem Raumschiff. Gut wir sind in verschiedenen Fahrzeugen und so weiter. Und man verbringt aber natürlich einen Großteil des Tages zusammen. Dass man zusammen auf einer Ausgrabung ist oder bei einer geologischen Beprobung oder bei einer Bohrung und man ist wirklich vom Frühstück bis zum Abendessen mehr oder weniger extremen Gruppensituation. So freie Tage, wo man dann auch mal alleine den ganzen Tag rumläuft, gibt es ja nicht. Also wir arbeiten ja durch. Es gibt keinerlei Freizeit, was sollte man auch machen. Man kann sich nicht in die Sonne legen, baden kann man auch nicht und so weiter. Und deswegen arbeitet man praktisch auch diese Wochen und Monate durch. Und dadurch ist man sehr eng. Und praktisch der einzige Freiraum, den man dann echt hat, ist wirklich in der Nacht. Deswegen habe ich zum Beispiel dann am Abend dann noch ausgedehnte Nachtspaziergänge gemacht, natürlich am liebsten wenn Mond ist.
Habe mich früher, bevor es GPS gab, auch oft verlaufen. Bin dann die ganze Nacht durchgelaufen, bis ich dann zum Glück am Morgen zurück zum Lager gefunden habe. Sind auch ganz interessante Erfahrungen, die man da machen kann. Oder wenn die Spuren plötzlich weg sind oder der letzte knipst das Licht aus oder der Mond verschwindet und plötzlich ist man stockdunkel in einem sehr schwierig überschaubaren Gelände. Aber es sind Gruppensituationen, die wirklich ganz wichtig sind und selbstverständlich den idealen Expedtionsteilnehmer gibt es nicht. Also einer, der jetzt sagen wir mal erst ein guter Wissenschaftler ist, gut für die Geländearbeit, gut für die Laborarbeit, gut dann beim Niederschreiben der Artikel. Der gruppentauglich ist, der Reifen wechseln kann, der gut kochen kann, der eine gute Laune bringt, der gut fotografieren kann, also den gibt es nicht.
So sucht man Astronauten aus.
So muss man es probieren. Aber ich würde sagen, meiste Zeit ist es so. Und wenn eben wirklich und einer, der mal schlechte Laune hat oder zwei eine gewisse Zeit, geht immer noch und aber wenn es mehr sind, dann ist es wirklich schwierig. Und ich hatte wirklich Glück auf diesen ja über 50 wirklich langen Expeditionen, dass es nur 1-2 Touren waren, an die ich überhaupt nicht mehr denken möchte. Weil da hat es eben überhaupt nichts funktioniert. Und da ist halt das Problem, wenn man mal gestartet ist, dann kann man nciht sagen, gut wenn du keine Lust hast, geh zurück kein Problem. Sondern man ist zusammen und man kann ja nicht die Expedition abbrechen, um jemanden zurückzubringen, nach einer tage- oder wochenlangen Anreise. Und das macht es dann wirklich ganz schlecht. Also ganz schlimm. Aber zum Glück ist das eigentlich fast nie passiert. Und der andere Aspekt ist halt, man lernt sich wahrscheinlich besser kennen in der Wüste. Also die Wüste kennt keine Geheimnisse.
Also wenn man nur ein paar Tage, geschweige denn ein paar Wochen, miteinander verbringt, dann kriegt man fast alles mit. Wirklich jeden kleinen Tick und jedes Defizit, was rauskommt. Und wenn man dann manchmal denkt, da geht jemand weg oder mit einem anderen Teammitglied geht einen Kilometer weg und erzählt dem und dann ist man gerade unterhalb des Windes und dann kriegt man jedes Wort mit, wie wenn man in einer Arena stehen würde. Also man kriegt wirklich alles mit über die Zeit und dann natürlich besonders unter Extrembedingungen. Wenn dann also schwierige Situationen sind, wenn an sich zigfach hintereinander im Sand festfährt und alle sind erschöpft. Oder wenn man also unfreundlichen Menschen dann doch irgendwo begegnet oder sonstigen Sachen. Und da ist es so halt meistens, dass sich dann eine Gruppe schon auch zusammenschweißt. Und deswegen mag ich ganz, das kann man nicht sagen, aber wenn es natürlich ein eingespieltes Team ist, wo man sich kennt, dann klappt es vom ersten Tag.
Da sitzt jeder Handgriff, man braucht überhaupt nicht mehr reden. Aber wenn es so neue Teams sind, und wenn dann am Anfang ein paar Schwierigkeiten auftreten, die also so hoffentlich keine schlimmen sind, aber das schweißt dann so eine Gruppe zusammen, weil dann meistens dieser normale Instinkt, wenn man das erste Mal wo hinkommt, dann weiß man erst mal alles besser. Und dann gibt es halt doch dann welche, die also etwas mehr Erfahrungen hatten und so weiter, wo dann auch dieser Karawanenführereffekt kommt, dass dann eben am Anfang, wenn die Karawane loszieht, einer will da gehen, einer fährt da, sagt, warum fährst du da, auf der anderen Seite kann man doch viel besser fahren, hätten wir uns nicht festgefahren. Nein über die Düne fahr ich nicht. Und wenn dann solche gewissen Vorfälle sind, die man dann gut regeln kann, dann schweißt eine Gruppe zusammen. Dann wird so ein gewisser Erfahrungsschatz respektiert und dann verläuft alles besser, als wenn so etwas am Anfang nicht passieren würde. Aber wie gesagt, meistens ist man mit einem erfahrenen Team zusammen und die anderen wollen nie mehr.
Die sagen, oh Gott, wenn man die fragt, willst du nicht nochmal mitkommen, die sagen, um Gottes Willen, erinnere mich nicht dran, war die schlimmste Zeit meines Lebens, nie wieder nie wieder. Da sind es dann klare Verhältnisse. Aber wenn dann eben zum Beispiel gelegentlich, wie gesagt in Einzelfällen, Kollegen mitkommen, die überhaupt keinen Bezug zur Wüste haben, überhaupt keinen Bezug zur Arbeit haben und das nur machen, weil sie eben auf einer Stelle sind, wo sie eben verpflichtet sind mitzukommen, das ist das schlimmste. Alles andere kann man verzeihen. Bloß man ist halt in dieser Gruppensituation dem ausgeliefert und da gibt es unendliche Geschichten von was da alles passieren kann auf so langen Reisen.
Wenn man dann vor Ort ist und ich weiß nicht, ob wir das jetzt schon erwähnt hatten, aber dieser Teil diese östliche Sahara ist so der weißeste Fleck, wenn man mal den Meeresboden rausnimmt, unter der Sonne liegenden Erde, über keinen Bereich weiß man weniger als über diese Region. Eben weil sie so schwer zu erforschen ist. Was kann man denn dann unter diesen Bedingungen da finden? Also auf was stößt man denn dann? Was findet man denn, wenn man durch diesen Vorhang geht?
Also man findet immer etwas. Man findet oft nicht das was man sucht. Aber man findet immer etwas, wenn man mit einem gewissen Blick und Grundkenntnissen losgeht. Und ich meine wie Goethe schon sagte, man findet nur das, was man kennt. Und das ist zum Beispiel manche Expedition, wo wir losgefahren sind, um sagen wir mal Fischknochen zu sammeln oder eben halt wirklich Lebewesen, die in den damaligen ja weit verbreiteten Seen gelebt haben. Wir sind zurückgekommen und wir haben nicht einen einzigen Fischknochen gefunden. Und ein anderes Mal fahren wir los mit einem ganz anderen Schwerpunkt, um jetzt sagen wir mal prähistorische Siedlungen zu finden und plötzlich finden wir zentnerweise Fischknochen. Also es ist der Blick, es hängt von vielen Faktoren ab. Im Nordtschad einmal haben wir so Dinosaurierknochen gefunden. Und dann bin ich mehrfach zurückgekommen in den nächsten Jahren und wir haben es nicht mehr gefunden.
Weil da einfach so eine von diesen Riesendünen, von diesen Barchan Dünen, die im Schnitt 200.000 Tonnen wiegen, sich trotzdem jedes Jahr bis 8 Meter bewegen, das sind gigantische Materialbilanzen. Weil einfach in den zwei Jahren ist die Düne weiter gewandert und dann liegt der Dinosaurier oder die Knochen wieder unter einer Düne und dann müsste man jetzt 50 Jahre warten und dann findet man den wieder. Es hängt ab von den Lichtverhältnissen häufig. Manchmal geht man so am helllichten Tag rüber, man findet nicht einen Steinartefakt, also so ein altes Steinwerkzeug oder diese Absplisse, die entstehen bei der Werkzeugherstellung oder Keramik, man geht stundenlang und man findet nichts. Und dann geht die Sonne unter in die Richtung und plötzlich glitzert es, es ist übersät. Dass man gesehen hat, man ist praktisch drüber gelaufen, ohne es zu erkennen.
Weil es zu hell ist oder was?
Weil es zu hell ist, je nach Beleuchtungsverhältnissen und so weiter. Und dann natürlich, wenn Sandtreiben ist, was natürlich sehr häufig ist, was ja dann auch eben Entdeckung von kleineren Objekten erschwert und so weiter.
Also Sandtreiben, diese kleinen Miniwinde.
Das auch, also das sind so Sandhosen, Sandwirbel, die gibt es natürlich auch ganz stark. Aber ich meine jetzt einfach das Sandtreiben, das ein richtiger Sandsturm, da sieht man in einem extremen nur noch wenige Meter weit. Aber der geht dann eben bis 2 Meter hoch. Staubstürme, die können ja Kilometer hochgehen. Die sind ja auch viel länger und im Endeffekt schwieriger, aber dieses normale Sandtreiben, bevor der Sandsturm kommt, dass wirklich nur am Boden eben immer so endlose Schleier von unendlichen Milliarden von Sandkörnern dann eben über die Oberfläche getrieben werden und dann sieht man dann natürlich auch nicht viel. Es sind halt wie gesagt wechselnde Bedingungen, aber die Wüste es gibt nichts, man kann egal wo, wenn man eine Panne hat, und Reifenpannen sind da sehr häufig, manchmal haben wir auf einer Expedition 30 Reifenpannen und so weiter, auch durch die starke Überladung natürlich, man hält an, man steigt aus und man findet einen Faustkeil, man findet Keramik.
Man findet einen Meteoriten, man findet irgendeine ganz seltene Pflanze. Man findet irgendein Insekt oder eine Spinne oder sonst was. Es ist jedes Mal. Und dann sucht man weiter und plötzlich gibt es immer noch mehr Fundplätze und so weiter. Also ich würde sagen, es gibt kaum einen Quadratmeter in der gesamten Sahara, wo ein offener Mensch mit offenem Blick und vielleicht auch gewissen Fachkenntnissen irgendetwas findet.
Quadratmeter würde ich sagen. Das ist natürlich wenn es auch nur Gesteine sind oder wenn es nur so kleine Mikroformationen sind von Dünen zum Beispiel. Oder zum Beispiel die Geomorphologie, die ja hochinteressant ist, gerade jetzt in der östlichen Sahara, wo man eben seit Millionen Jahren diese extrem konstanten Passatwinde hat. Die jetzt als wie ein nicht endendes Sandstrahlgebläse die ganze Oberfläche geformt haben. Und gerade im nordöstlichen TsTschad, wo man sagt, das ist das windreichste Gebiet und das ausgeprägteste Gebiet für eine äolische, für eine durch den Sand durchgeführte Formung der Erdoberfläche. Wo man da zig Kilometer lange Korridore hat, in dem härtesten vulkanischen Gestein, was eben da herausziseliert wurde von diesem Wind, von diesen Millionen von Sandstürmen, die das Gelände geformt haben. Und da findet man natürlich alle Formen, die man sich vorstellen kann.
Quadratmeter?
Von mikroskopischen kleinen Formen, die durch den Wind hergestellt werden, bis zu den größten Torbögen auf dem Globus, bis zu unzähligen Felsüberhängen, bis zu Sphinxen, natürlichen Sphinxen, Millionen von Formen, die alle Formen einnehmen. Manche, die wirklich der Sphinx in Gizeh in Ägypten ähneln, aber die auch alle anderen Formen haben. Alle Gesichter, Sandsteinpfeiler, Formen, Gesichter, Tiere, alles was es gibt, die durch diesen Wind natürlich zustande gekommen sind. Und die zumindest in den Gebieten wie Tibesti oder wo eben noch ein paar Menschen leben, dann natürlich auch respektiert sind, zum Teil gefürchtet sind, in der Vergangenheit erst recht. Wenn man die in so einem Schummerlicht sieht oder im Sandsturm, wo man wirklich Angst haben könnte, zumindest wenn man da einen Vitaminmangel hat und ausgetrocknet ist und so weiter, wo man dann alles mögliche erkennt.
Was dann auch verstärkt wird durch den Wind, er ja auch alle möglichen Geräusche erzeugt. Richtige Töne, von Flöten bis Donnern, bis brüllenden Geräuschen. Wenn zum Beispiel so Dünenhänge ins Rutschen kommen, das hört sich an wie ein Bombengeschwader. Wenn dann Milliarden von Milliarden von Sandkörnern ins Rutschen kommen und dann eben aneinander reiben und das ist dann in dem Echo von so einer Düne wird das dann noch verstärkt und man guckt zum Himmel und denkt, es kommen jetzt hunderte von Bombenflugzeugen, das ist gar nicht so. Es ist nur der Sand. Und dieses Gesamtbild dort, was man in dieser scheinbar unbelebten Welt findet, das ist so voller Dinge. Wie gesagt, man findet einzelne Mineralien überall, die sich gebildet haben in Gesteinen und so weiter. Und selbst wenn man dann mal wirklich in Gebieten ist, wo man sagt, so das ist jetzt das Ende, geologisch gesehen.
Das ist also noch viel weiter als die Oberfläche des Mars, als unsere langfristige Zukunftsperspektive, ist keine Frage, dass da irgendwann das Wasser weg ist und dann die Erde so aussieht wie der Mars. Aber selbst in diesen Gebieten, die mich immer fasziniert haben, wo dann wirklich nur noch – wir nennen das – das Basement oder eben der Keller, wo dann wirklich nur noch das präkambrische meinetwegen Grundgebirge erhalten ist, was durch den Wind und diese Stabilität, diese Klimabedingungen eben wirklich jetzt glatt geschliffen ist und jetzt glatt, und selbst das. Da ist zwar jetzt wirklich nichts mehr zu finden sagen wir mal, außer so einem granitischen Boden, aber selbst das hat eine riesige Faszination, weil selbst da wird man dann bestimmte Spuren finden, sei es ein Meteorit, sei es eine bestimmte Windformung und so weiter und so fort.
Und gerade diese weiten Landschaften, wo man sagt, das ist jetzt der definitive leblose Endzustand allen Lebens, finde ich hat eine unglaubliche Faszination und das zieht sich dann zum Teil bis zum Horizont 360 Grad außen rum. Und deswegen konnte ich nie verstehen, wenn Leute zurückkommen und sagen, Mensch wir waren dort, da ist ja gar nichts, was erzählen die denn alles und ist alles langweilig. Wie gesagt, man braucht einen Zugang dazu, und dann ist es nirgends langweilig.
Wie nichts ist denn da? Also meine ich, so richtig gar kein nachweisbares Leben mehr oder ist es so das, was wir so üblicherweise wahrnehmen, nur nicht mehr zu finden?
Ja. Nein in den Kernzonen ist absolut nichts. Da gibt es auch keine Bakterien. Wir haben Untersuchungen gemacht mit Filtern. Keine Kontamination, es ist nichts. Es ist also alles rein mineralisch und kein Leben. Jetzt habe ich zum Beispiel einen Botanikerfreund, den Frank Darius, der auch wirklich manchmal dann sagt, das stimmt doch gar nicht und der findet dann einen winzigen Pilz oder ein winziges Grashälmchen, aber das auch nur noch so lange, wie gewisse Bodenfeuchte da ist, so lange noch ein Minimum an Niederschlag ist und dann wirklich in den richtigen Zentralbereichen, da ist dann wirklich absolut nichts, außer Sand und Fels und kein Lebewesen. Natürlich kein Lebewesen stimmt ja auch nicht, weil es gibt ja die Zugvögel. Und manche Zugvögel stürzen ab und unter Umständen kann sich da auch in den entlegensten Regionen dann ein Falke überleben, oder auch eine Schlange, die dann von diesen abgestürzten Zugvögeln lebt.
Oder ein Zugvogel, der einmal im Jahr, der reicht dann aus bis ins nächste Jahr. Also man muss vorsichtig sein mit absolut leblos. Aber nach normalen Maßstäben ist es sicher der lebloseste Raum, wenn man jetzt eben von den Polarwüsten absieht, die man so finden kann.
Findet man da viele so Zugvögel? Also die östliche Sahara ist ja jetzt gar nicht so ein Zugvögelüberflugsgebiet oder?
Ja stimmt, das ist sicher nicht die Hauptachse, aber es ist auch deswegen, und das gilt ja für viele Aspekte, man weiß es nicht. Es gibt in der ganzen Ostsahara ja keine einzige Klimastation oder jedenfalls in den wenigen Oasen und da funktionieren sie häufig auch nicht. Es gibt auch keine Vogelflugbeobachtungsstationen. Aber wir haben öfter gesehen, und das allererste Mal Anfang der 80er, wo wir fahren zum Beispiel Selima Sand Sheet, das ist also ein absolut ebenes Sandgebiet, optisch rein, da liegt nichts und wenn irgendwas liegt über dem Sanddurchmesser, also sagen wir mal 1-2 Millimeter, dann ist es entweder ein Meteorit oder ein prähistorisches Artefakt. Weil alles andere kann da aus geologischen Gründen überhaupt nicht hinkommen. Und plötzlich sehen wir da schwarze Flecken und alles. Wo man natürlich erst mal einen Schreck kriegt, Moment das sind jetzt Leute, ist das Militär, brennt es? Man fährt immer näher so im Gegenlicht vor der untergehenden Sonne, so richtig schwarze bewegende Flecken.
Und dann denkt man, ist da jetzt ein Vulkanausbruch oder ist da eine Ölquelle, die plötzlich sich ausbreitet und dann verschwindet, das ändert sich. Bis wir dann endlich so nahe dran waren, und dann durch die Ferngläser erkennen konnten, dass es ein riesiger Schwarm von Störchen war, der da eben zwischengelandet ist und sich ausgeruht hat. Und das auch in einem Gebiet, wo damals Anfang der 80er Jahre überhaupt keiner wusste, dass eben da zumindest eine Bahn rübergeht. Und da gibt es also schon mehr. Also wir sehen je nachdem in welchen Jahreszeiten wir unterwegs sind, sehen wir schon öfter Zugvögel. Aber sicher es ist jetzt nicht die Hauptsaharatraverse.
Und man stolpert jetzt auch nicht die ganze Zeit über tote Vögel?
Nein nein. Da freut man sich, wenn man viele hat die auch nur abstürzen und dann findet man eben noch die Nistplätze von eben Falken, die dann davon leben und die Knochen dann da hinbringen. Das ist auch sehr interessant, weil daran kann man ja dann auch untersuchen, welche Vögel kommen überhaupt dahin, wovon ernährt sich jetzt dieser Einsiedlerfalke und so weiter. Es gibt auch ganz selten eben Heuschrecken, die aber eher in den Randbereichen das Gebiet queren. Zum Teil auch vom Wind getrieben. Und wo es dann auch wieder viele Gemeinsamkeiten gibt, dass zum Beispiel wahrscheinlich eben diese uralten prähistorischen Wanderwege, die sagen wir mal vor 10.000 oder 8.000 Jahren von den prähistorischen Menschen benutzt wurden, die dann später dann genutzt wurden, als dann die Esel aufkamen. Die dann wieder diesen alten Pfaden gefolgt sind. Dann kamen vor maximal 2.000 Jahren die Kamele, dann sind sie denen gefolgt.
Und irgendwann dann später sind dann halt in manchen Gebieten die ersten Asphaltstraßen da vor 10-30 Jahren gebaut worden. Und dass die häufig den Orten folgen, wo die Heuschrecken gelandet sind oder wo die Vögel gelandet sind, weil das sind die Regionen, wo es eben während der Feuchtzeit Seen gab oder Tümpel, die dann ausgetrocknet sind, wo dann das Grundwasser näher an der Oberfläche war und das können offensichtlich sowohl die Vögel wie die Heuschrecken auch spüren. Und die haben sich da niedergelassen, so dass man praktisch so also Tier-Mensch, die dann für heute in der Sahara an vielen Orten noch den Verlauf der Asphaltstraßen angelegt hat. Und was sicher die damaligen Menschen, die viel näher mit der Natur waren, beobachtet haben, die dann geguckt haben, warum landen jetzt da gerade die Heuschreckenschwärme und nicht da? Und dann haben sie gegraben und haben gemerkt, das ist ein bisschen feucht. Und gräbt man tiefer ist man am Wasser. Und das ist halt dieses Zusammenspiel, was man sehr gut sehen kann.
Noch so eine subjektive Frage, was ist denn so das Schönste eigentlich in der Wüste?
Also das Schönste ist halt so dieser Mangel an äußeren Reizen. Das heißt jedesmal, wenn man in der Wüste war, früher gerade, wenn man mehrere Monate war, dann kam man zurück und man ist wie durchgepustet. Das ist wirklich wie der frische Wind geht durchs Gehirn, dass alle Probleme, also vielleicht nicht alle, aber die meisten Probleme, die wir hier in unseren westlichen und inzwischen ja schon fast weltweiten Alltagslebensbedingungen finden, dass die völlig verschwinden. Ich meine, wie soll man jetzt einem Nomaden erklären, dass eins der größten Probleme in unserem Leben ist, einen Parkplatz zu finden, wo man alles hat. Und dass einfach diese Konzentration, dieses einfache wirklich schon asketische Leben, wo man wirklich dankbar ist über jeden Schluck Wasser, den man trinkt, also kalt ja sowieso nicht. Und dann kommt man danach zurück, öffnet den Wasserhahn, hat unbegrenzt gutes trinkbares Wasser, was ja bis heute die meisten Afrikaner nicht haben.
Nicht mal in den Hauptstädten der Länder und so weiter. Oder dass man halt wirklich sehr eintönig lebt. Manchmal wirklich nur von Datteln am ganzen Tag. Und dann kommt man zurück und ist in diesen unvorstellbaren paradiesischen Lebensbedingungen. Also dieser Kontrast, der das also wirklich für mich immer unheimlich faszinierend macht. Und auf der anderen Seite, wenn man dann eben ganz selten, also ich mach schon lange nicht mehr, dass ich nur einen Kurzwellenempfänger mitnehme oder so, wenn man dann eben hört, was hier die Diskussion bestimmt und die Öffentlichkeitsarbeit. Worüber sich die Menschen Sorgen machen und irgendwelche parteipolitischen Dinge, das ist wie absurdes Theater, wenn man das dann weit entfernt mitten in der Wüste 1.000 Kilometer von der nächsten menschlichen Besiedlung hört. Und dann auch, was mich dann immer sehr fasziniert, das sind diese kurzen aber sehr intensiven Bewegungen. Wenn man dann halt irgendwann mal, sicher nicht in den zentralen Gebieten, aber dann Menschen begegnet, die ja unter ähnlichen Bedingungen leben, die Nomaden.
Dass da, auch wenn man sich manchmal überhaupt nicht verständigen kann, weil die nicht mal arabisch reden können, aber da ist eine Geistesverwandtschaft und auch eine Freundschaft und eine Herzlichkeit. Auch wenn jeder dann ein paar Stunden später wieder seinen Weg geht. Man wird sich nie wieder sehen und trotzdem sind es also Begegnungen, die man dann also selten vergisst. Da hat man ein paar Fotos. Und halt dieses Leben am Abend draußen zu übernachten, nach sehr anstrengenden Arbeitstagen. Es ist wirklich wie gesagt nie eine Stunde praktisch frei. Man arbeitet und isst und schläft praktisch, das ist alles Teil der Arbeit sozusagen. Aber wenn man dann in seinem Schlafsack liegt und viele gehen dann immer ein paar hundert Meter weg vom Camp, wo die Fahrzeuge stehen. Dann klappert es nicht und man hört nicht, wenn einer schnarcht und so weiter und so fort. Man liegt da wirklich, das ist wirklich, wie ein Paradies.
Man guckt auf die Sterne, die sich bewegen. Man kriegt jedes Geräusch mit. Man wird wirklich Teil der Natur. Und ich sage immer, die eigene Existenz einerseits verliert an jeglicher Bedeutung. Man denkt, Mensch was ist man. Man guckt in dieses Weltall, in dieses einzigartig klare Weltall, was man ja nirgends sonst so klar sieht, wie in der Wüste durch die Trockenheit natürlich. Man sieht wie sich der Mond oder der Orion, die Nacht bewegt außen rum. Und wenn man dann am Morgen aufsteht und man merkt, oh unter der Matte krabbelt auch so ein Skorpion raus, den würde man niemals töten. Weil man sagt, guten Morgen toll, du hast auch unter schweren Bedingungen. Er hat sich da unter gelegt. Man würde den nie töten zum Beispiel. Und gleichzeitig gewinnt eben das Leben an Bedeutung, dass man eben weiß, wie kostbar ist nur ein Schluck Wasser oder ein paar Datteln, die entscheiden, ob man stirbt oder überlebt.
Und man denkt natürlich auch, man kriegt eine ganz andere Weltsicht. Leider wird man dann zurückgeholt. Früher hat das bei mir wirklich wochenlang angehalten, bis ich praktisch wieder eingeholt wurde von dem Alltagsleben hier in Europa. Und jetzt natürlich, wenn man zurück kommt, man öffnet die Email oder sogar schon in den Hauptstädten und dann sind da angestaute Emails von 6-8 Wochen, dann ist man sofort wieder eingeholt. Also ich glaube diese Nachwirkung, die ist immer kürzer geworden, leider. Aber es ist sehr wichtig und ich glaube, es tut einem sehr gut und es ist eine unglaublich gesunde Welt. Denn wenn man gesund hingeht und sich kein Bein bricht oder von einer Schlange gebissen wird, das ist natürlich dann schon schlimm, aber es ist unglaublich gesund. Und die meisten Wüstenforscher sind auch alle sehr alt geworden im Gegensatz zu vielen, die in den feuchten Tropen gearbeitet haben. Das ist also wesentlich ungesünder.
Ja so viele Krankheiten kann man sich da nicht einfangen oder?
Nichts. Also es ist eigentlich steril. Man kann, wenn man was mitbringt, jemanden anstecken, aber wie gesagt, die Gefahr ist, dass man sich irgendwie mechanisch verletzt oder halt die Schlangen und Skorpione sind da nicht so gefährlich. Spinnenbisse sind auch unangenehm. Also es gibt halt wirklich ein paar lebensgefährliche Schlangen, wo man nur sehr geringe Überlebenschancen hat, wenn man wirklich gebissen würde. Das ist mit das Hauptrisiko. Aber wenn man da eben entsprechend aufpasst, passiert das also zum Glück nur sehr sehr selten. Aber sonst ist es die absolut gesunde Lebensweise. Man schläft natürlich auch sehr viel. Weil man hat jeden Tag 12 Stunden Licht, 12 Stunden Dunkelheit. Um 18 Uhr wird es meistens dunkel, dann ist man also wenn der Mond nicht scheint ohne Taschenlampe kann man da gar nichts machen. Dann schläft man viel länger. Man hat einen viel gleichmäßigeren Rhythmus, man ist eben nicht diesen ganzen Verlockungen der Zivilisation ausgesetzt, die einen in jedem Supermarkt da überall einen angucken.
Es ist also sehr sehr gesunde, also sowohl physisch wie mentale Umgebung. Aber wie gesagt, es ist eine sehr asketische Angelegenheit und damit muss man klarkommen. Eben nicht mal den Fernseher anzumachen oder ins Kino zu gehen oder in die Kneipe zu gehen und ein Bier zu trinken oder überhaupt Sozialleben zu haben. Natürlich das ist der Preis, der größte Preis, den man zahlen muss, das ist ja gerade Familienleben oder von seinen Partnerinnen, Frauen, Kindern getrennt zu sein. Also ich sage mal diese Trennung von den Kindern das war das Schlimmste. Und gerade früher, wenn man monatelang kein Lebenszeichen hatte und drei Monate nichts wusste. Und normalerweise man braucht sowieso die Voraussetzungen dieser Art von Forschung ist, dass man entsprechenden familiären Hintergrund hat oder Freunde oder Freundinnen hat. Anders geht das gar nicht.
Also die das entweder mittragen oder die es nicht gibt.
Genau, die es mittragen oder die es nicht gibt. Das ist natürlich ideal. So wie Humboldt sagte, als seine Mutter fragte, Mensch willst du nicht endlich heiraten? Und er sagt, nein ein Forscher, da passt eine Familie nicht rein. Ich werde nie heiraten und so. Das wäre ein hoher Preis, den würde ich nicht nehmen. Aber man braucht die entsprechenden Umfelder. Und die halt so eine On-Off-Situation, dass sie selbständig ist. Und damals, vielmehr heute, theoretisch hat man ein Satellitentelefon, aber wenn was ernsthaftes passiert, wo man schnell reagieren müsste und man bräuchte im allerallerbesten Fall eine Woche, um zurück zu sein, da ist es natürlich in akuten Fällen schon viel zu spät. Und deswegen sehe ich das mit gemischten Gefühlen. Früher wusste man, jeder ist auf sich gestellt, weil man kann ja kurzfristig sowieso nichts machen. Und Expeditionen abzubrechen, die haben natürlich einen hohen Preis für alle Beteiligten. Und bei denen monatelangen Reisen kann natürlich viel passieren. Aber ich glaube das Schlimmste ist halt, wenn man dann eben manchmal sich Sorgen macht, oh vielleicht hat jetzt mein Kind da die Probleme, man kann nichts machen.
Da kann man sich auch ziemlich reinsteigern. Weil man kann ja nicht reagieren. Und heute kann man anrufen und sagen, und dann ist man wieder total beruhigt, wenn wieder alles in Ordnung ist.
Ich wundere mich sowieso, dass die Expeditionszeiten so ausgedehnt sind, dass man da wirklich so lange bleiben möchte, trotz dieser widrigen Bedingungen. Warum ist das so? Weil es irgendwie teurer wäre?
Nein es geht nicht anders. Also früher war es ja noch extremer. Da ist man also von Berlin aus oder von Köln aus mit einem riesigen Tross von Fahrzeugen erst mal meinetwegen nach Venedig gefahren. Dann ist man auf die Fähre, da war man dann ein paar Tage, über Kreta, bis man in Alexandria ankam. Dann hing man da erst mal ein paar Tage im Zoll fest. Dann war man in Kairo, hat manchmal sechs Wochen gewartet, bis die Arbeitsgenehmigungen kamen. Mit der ägyptischen Bürokratie, hat ja 5.000 Jahre Tradition, ist es immer das Schwierigste gewesen, in anderen Ländern ging es schneller. Dann fährt man erst los. Ich war manchmal im Extremen über zwei Monate unterwegs, bevor ich überhaupt in meinem Arbeitsgebiet ankam. Zum Beispiel im Wadi Howar im nördlichen Sudan, weil wir damals immer von Alexandria über Kairo gefahren sind. Dachla Die letzte ägyptische Oase und dann fuhren wir ja tausende Kilometer, ohne einen einzigen Sudanesen zu sehen, weil es dort halt keine Bewohner gibt. Und bis man dann im Arbeitsgebiet ankommt. Und das Gleiche natürlich dann wieder zurück und dann wieder nach Kairo und wieder auf die Fähre und wieder zurückfahren.
Ja gut, so war das früher und heute?
Jetzt ja heute, jetzt haben wir die Fahrzeuge. Wo haben wir die? In Karthum, zum Teil in Kairo oder selbst in Dachla, wo wir eben eine Forschungsstation haben oder in ???. Aber von dort die Anreise zum Beispiel in Tibesti, wo ich ja die letzten Jahre den Schwerpunkt habe, da ist 10 Tage Anreise. Man braucht bis zu 10 Tage, bis man eben jetzt sagen wir mal im nördlichen Tibesti angekommen ist. Und 10 Tage zurück, überwiegend off-road mit vielen mechanischen Problemen und so weiter. Und diese lange Anfahrt, man kann ja nicht 10 Tage hinfahren, ist dann da eine Woche und fährt zurück, das würde in keinem Verhältnis stehen.
Ja okay.
Und daran liegt es, dass man halt wirklich die Anfahrt und der Aufwand der Vorbereitung und natürlich auch die Kosten so groß sind, dass jede Minute, jede Stunde wichtig ist, und man eigentlich immer noch viel länger blieben müsste. Vor allem weil man natürlich die besten Funde meisten immer erst die letzten Tage hat, das ist auch so eine Regel. Und kürzer geht es nicht. Also unter 6 Wochen in entlegenen Gebieten, da braucht man gar nicht losfahren.
Also ich bin erschlagen von den Parallelen zum Aufenthalt in der Raumstation. Also auch eine ziemlich teure Anfahrt, extremer technischer Aufwand auch, um dort vor Ort sozusagen überleben zu können. Da ist Wasser ja nun auch recht knapp. Die psychologische Isolation kommt noch dazu. Klar eingeschränkte Kommunikationsmittel. Aber man kann halt auch nicht mal eben schnell nach Hause. Also ist doch schon einiges ähnlich. Und mir würde jetzt so ansonsten nur noch die im Polareis einfallen, die glaube ich eine ähnliche Isolation haben.
Genau. Die haben natürlich die Isolation, die Arbeitsbedingungen sind dort wesentlich angenehmer. Entweder es ist total klimatisiert und wenn sie rausgehen haben sie eben Mondanzüge an, wo sie die Kälte überhaupt nicht spüren. Wir spüren die, wenn es -10 Grad hat und einen eisigen Weg, der über den Chill Faktor dann die empfundene Temperatur -20 macht. Und man hat halt nur einen Schlafsack. Und man wacht auf und man ist also halb eingesandet. Oder am Tag dann 50 Grad im Schatten wie gesagt oder 45 Grad, den es ja nicht gibt. Es gibt keinen Schatten dort und das den ganzen Tag. Und dann ist eben die Temperatur 60-70 Grad. Wie in der Sauna den ganzen Tag, nur man kann danach nicht duschen. Und da sind die Bedingungen ja doch … in der Antarktis natürlich die Isolation ist vergleichbar. Die Gruppensituation auch. Aber im Notfall ist natürlich sofort ein Hubschrauber da. Man hat ständig Internetverbindung und Telefonverbindung und so weiter. Also da würde ich sagen, ist es bei uns immer noch einen Zacken härter.
Schwitzt man eigentlich in diesen trockenen Gebieten überhaupt noch nennenswert?
Genau. Man schwitzt ganz extrem, bloß man merkt es nicht. Und das ist natürlich die Voraussetzung, dass man das Wochen und Monate machen kann, ohne zu duschen. Man kann sich natürlich partiell reinigen, man kann mit einem feuchten Waschlappen. Man kann mit einem Liter schon eine gute Ganzkörperreinigung durchführen. Aber es kostet eben einen Liter und vielleicht sogar zwei Liter. Und Haarewaschen, da wird dann schon sehr kritisch. Und das geht natürlich nur, weil jede Feuchtigkeit natürlich sofort verdunstet und man deswegen also auch nie stinkt, das ist ganz klar. Das wäre sonst … also nur ein paar Tage in New York ohne zu duschen im Sommer, wäre also unmöglich. Und dann den ganzen Tag zusammen sitzen auf der Arbeit oder im Auto, das ginge nicht. und das fällt eben weg, weil eben dieser Geruch entfernt wird sozusagen. Und man kann sich ja auch mit Sand reinigen. Nicht nur unser Geschirr wird gereinigt und die Töpfe mit Sand, sondern man kann sich auch die Hände abreiben. Und alleine das Sandstrahlgebläse, dem man ausgesetzt ist, hält einen also organisch sauber.
Und richtigen Dreck gibt es ja nicht. Es gibt ja nur, also der meiste Dreck das sind noch die alten Seeablagerungen, die auch so einen organischen Anteil haben. Aber sonst ist man ja praktisch mit ganz sauberem Sand und Fels im Kontakt, und da wird man also nicht so dreckig wie einen Tag in einer deutschen Großstadt.
Und keine Bakterien.
Und keine Bakterien und keine Viren und überhaupt nichts.
Keine Keime, keine gar nichts.
Absolut nichts, absolut nichts. Hypersteril.
Und wenn man dann wieder zurückkommt, was ist dann das, was man doch irgendwie vermisst hat, außer jetzt Kinobesuche und so etwas?
Ja das wichtig ist natürlich immer dann die Rückkehr zu der Familie und zu den Kindern, wenn dann alles gutgeht, das ist dann natürlich immer der Höhepunkt. Wenn man am Flughafen abgeholt wird oder man kommt zu Hause an. Das ist dann …
Aber wenn man das Soziale mal rausnimmt, das ist ja irgendwie nachvollziehbar. Also einfach nur so dieses von der Umwelt her. Also von dem wie die Erde sich einem so präsentiert.
Also da reagiert wahrscheinlich auch jeder anders. Also ich persönlich habe schon immer … oder ich bin fast immer schlecht gelaunt, wenn wir aus der Wüste kommen nach Wochen oder Monaten in die erste Oase. Dann habe ich schon immer schlechte Laune.
Riecht man denn überhaupt was?
Ja ja sicher. Also das natürlich. Alleine Oasen. Ach in der Wüste?
Aber in der Wüste?
Da riecht man unglaublich. Man riecht unglaublich gut. Weil es ist unmöglich, ich sage es, man kennt sich nach einer Woche gemeinsam in der Wüste besser, als wahrscheinlich der eigene Partner oder so. Weil man einfach alles mitkriegt. Es hat jeder kleine Geruch, man sieht, wenn einer jetzt irgendwas trinkt oder eine Zigarette raucht oder irgendein Bonbon ist oder ein Stück Wurst, das riecht man in dieser trockenen Luft zig Meter weit.
Ja okay, aber man riecht sozusagen nur die anderen oder sich. Aber man riecht an sich in der Wüste, also gibt es da überhaupt nennenswerte olfaktorische Einflüsse?
Nein nein, das gehört auch zu der Reizarmut. Also sagen wir mal richtig jetzt nur von der Umgebung, da riecht man nichts. Natürlich wenn da irgendein Strauch ist, der vielleicht blüht, dann riecht man es. Es sind ein paar Insekten dran oder Bienen oder sonst was, da dann schon. Oder wenn Kameldung liegt oder irgendeine Gazelle.
Na klar, aber jetzt richtig im toten Bereich.
Richtig nichts null. Also ich mit meiner Nase rieche absolut nichts.
Das heißt in dem Moment, wo man dann in eine Oase kommt oder auch wieder zurückkommt, dann ist es vor allem auch ein olfaktorisches Fest.
Ganz ganz stark. Aber wie gesagt für mich dann gemischte Gefühle. Weil man kommt als Nomade praktisch zurück zu den Sesshaften oder ins Niltal zu den Fellachen, die seit 5.000 Jahren in ihrem kleinen Dorf wohnen und ihre Bewässerung machen, das ist ja ganz wichtig und der Landwirtschaft und alles. Aber da bin ich immer schlecht gelaunt. Und wenn ich dann in die großen Städte komme, die ja früher noch klein waren. Ich meine Katum vor 35 Jahren das war ja fast ein Dorf. Jetzt ist es eine boomende Riesenstadt. Also da werde ich dann noch schlechter gelaunt und wenn ich dann erst im Stau stehe dann noch mehr. Und wenn ich das sehe und da ist halt was mich antreibt, wirklich halt zurückzukommen zur Familie und Freunden. Aber da habe ich wirklich eine Abneigung. Und erstmal nicht jetzt, das ich da jetzt sagen wir mal sofort losgehe und anfange, literweise Wein zu trinken. Also dann braucht man eigentlich, das holt einen dann ein. Aber es so eine gewisse Melancholie immer, wenn man dann praktisch die Wüste verlässt und dann kommt das erste Kamel, der erste Esel, die ersten Menschen.
Die ersten Dörfer und dann beginnt der ganze Dreck und die Plastiktüten, also da geht es mir jedesmal nicht gut.
Nachvollziehbar. Herr Kröpelin ich würde sagen, hier machen wir mal einen Punkt.
Fortsetzung folgt.
Vielleicht auch nur ein Semikolon. Vielen dank für die Reise in die Wüste und auch in eine Form der Forschung, die man jetzt vielleicht nicht so oft wiederfindet. Ich beneide Sie jetzt wahrscheinlich nur aus dem Stand heraus, aber am meisten für diesen Blick nach oben. Weil der Sternenhimmel ist bestimmt ziemlich intensiv. Aber danke erst mal für die Ausführungen.
Sehr gerne, auch wenn die Forschung wieder ein etwas in den Hintergrund getreten ist zum Teil. Aber das ist halt bei der Thematik, das müsste man dann mal in einem anderen Gespräch machen. Wo man dann nur über die Forschung spricht.
Ja da waren ja auch schon viele Aspekte mit dabei.
Natürlich klar.
Gut, und ja vielen Dank auch an alle hier fürs Zuhören bei Forschergeist. Ich sage, tschüss und bis bald.